so over this weekend we got news that
more documents have been found at the uh
the Joe Biden residents but that's not
the the big news the big news is that on
a background screening request
application Hunter Biden listed this
address as his current residence and
that he paid 49
910 per month for this Wilmington
Delaware residence and I said look
even if he was renting the whole house
to himself that's like five grand per
month in Wilmington Delaware that's like
the high end
for what reason was Hunter Biden Peng
ten times the average rent to live in
his dad's house I don't know maybe this
was how he got the uh 10 for the big guy
sent his way how do you clean money if
if Joe Biden setting up the business
Hunter Biden's doing it how does the
money then go from Hunter to Joe and get
cleaned up
just pay rent and when Joe Biden files
his taxes he doesn't itemize which
apartment generated which which income
he just says rental income X and then
put some ridiculous number
so it could be that we'll talk about
that in a whole bunch more surrounding
Joan Hunter Biden plus we've got the
world economic Forum predicting a global
recession and then of course Wyoming is
going to ban electric cars to shore up
the fossil fuel industry man
what an interesting week my voice is
also still kind of crummy but uh bear
with us as uh we're we're coming back
into the swing of things thanks for
hanging out before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly click that
join us button and you'll get access to
exclusive uncensored segments from this
show Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
and I will also add you will be aiding
in our cultural Endeavors the haters
told me I wasn't allowed to skate in the
local spots they actually tell me that
they told other people that and so we
did an event we showed up it was great a
bunch of locals were there skating had a
great time people were giving me fist
bumps they want to make you think they
control these spaces they do not simply
by showing up and doing our thing we won
for all the people who are scared to
speak out I'm telling you don't be
afraid these people do not have the
power you think they do so thank you all
for the support smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Osiris of middlemaga let's go
let's get it I'm Osiris and I have a
website and a YouTube channel called
middle Mega and I'm all over I'm all
over the map politically I like
Libertarians I like Meg I like the
populist left Tim's had Kim Iverson on
gen Perlman I really like them so I I
started out after the pandemic and I saw
the craziness like you're talking about
Biden and people trying to you know go
after you for skating in the park and
I'm like I gotta get a mic grab the
Canon M50 went in my basement and just
started recording and I'm here right on
man thanks for joining us it'd be fun
thank you all right we got Luke hey guys
lots of crazy news today as today we
also celebrate the day that the
government assassinated someone and then
made a holiday for that particular
someone paid for it by of course your
tax dollars that's why today I'm wearing
my make taxation theft again shirt and
if you agree with that you could get the
shirt on the best politicalshirts.com
and of course support my efforts here
thank you again so much for having me
Ian hi everyone Ian craw doing really
well thanks for asking Luke how's your
uh the new year uh what was the thing
resolution yeah how's that going
building muscle so far so good I've had
positive feedback
um I saw him carrying on a garbage bag
full of chimichangas yeah I'll go I'll
just keep pushing I mean he's
cultivating Mass that's my mind when I
get started on something I get obsessive
about it for the most part which is why
I don't do a lot of things but when I do
I do them well he sleeps very well yes I
I rest is a big part of it
um a lot of rest oh it's all of it it's
rock and roll baby
hey and I am serge.com as always guys
let's just start rolling all right let's
jump into this first story we have this
tweet from Miranda Devine she says in
2018 Hunter Biden claimed he owned the
house where Joe Biden kept classified
documents alongside his Corvette in the
garage take a look at this on this silly
little document you can see oh I can't
even scroll down I got to do it this way
here we go you scroll down and you can
see right here monthly rent 49 910.
he lived there move-in date March 20th
20s I'm sorry March 2017 to February
2018. so 11 months he's paying his dad
50 Grand and you can see current address
is the Wilmington address
what's uh what's Hunter doing spending
10 times the high end for rent to live
in this house I mean look you want to
talk about the documents that should not
have been in those properties you want
to talk about who else had access to
those documents at his pen his UPenn uh
office as well as his house and it all
sounds very dirty and then from that we
are now kind of discovering that uh
Hunter Biden I I think this is this is
this is evidence of funneling money
money surreptitiously to his dad now I
want to say proof but I it is possible
he fabricated that number and he's
trying to make it seem like he spends a
lot of money I don't know why he would
do that so I think this is very very
strong evidence that that's what he was
doing he was funneling money to his dad
well it is a lot of money and it doesn't
really make sense in that particular
neighborhood but hunter Biden is a big
spender he spends tens of thousands of
dollars on sex workers and on a lot of
drugs there's also a a text message that
the New York Post is reporting on
specifically detailing how Hunter Biden
allegedly was covering a lot of his
family expenses and giving as much as 50
percent of his earnings to his father
this is according to some of the text
messages through the laptop that were
leaked one specific text message reads
quote I hope you all can do what I did
and pay for everything for this entire
family for 30 years Hunter raged to his
daughter Naomi in January 2019. it's
really hard but don't worry unlike Pop I
won't make you give me half your salary
that's Hunter Biden texting his daughter
that's that's pretty telling there yeah
you say yeah what we see here is
evidence of washing money like you said
I'm not going to say proof but this
looks like they're doing the laundry and
I think this is real there's two things
Maga came in the house you just had Matt
Gates on Friday Mega's really they're
going to do the church-like commission
and that's going to put pressure on
Biden that's why we're starting to see
some of these things come out in my
opinion and they have to look impartial
so now they can say we're going after
Trump and Biden and then on top of that
I don't think Democrats want Biden in
2024 are you serious yeah so it solves
two problems for them I think and Joe
Scarborough is on TV along with Mika
going after Biden because he's handled
this sloppily they had the message like
we don't think there's any more
documents out there then how many did we
see three or four now yeah the number
one thing with crisis management is you
nip it in the butt you say here's
everything and then you don't have to
talk about it anymore so something's
something's wrong I think he's in danger
you brought up a very good point because
you know the corporate media usually
regurgitates any slop he throws on the
floor and they and they love it they
suck it right up they spit it right at
you looking at you smiling as they ah
they're propaganda and their bull crap
they got him elected if it wasn't for
the corporate media Joe Biden hiding in
his basement would not be president of
the United States right now also social
media also the intelligence agencies
also a lot of black money but but that's
a separate topic here so I do think
there's something behind the scenes
happening right now it could be him
saying hey I'm going to be running in
2024. I'm I wanted to be the next
president of the United States and some
powerful people saying no you're not
you're gonna play ball and you're going
to give this to Buddha judge or Kamala
or Oprah or Michelle whoever it may be
but but I think there's a larger power
Striker and and it might not even be
around the election it could be
something related to the collapse of the
economy the globalists or
internationalists the the shadowy elites
could be like we're going to crash this
economy under your watch he's like nope
don't do it who knows what's going on
here but this smells a foot here because
this doesn't really add up to what
usually happens in Washington DC I think
it's weird because Joe Biden
is the establishment they don't need to
to do this to get rid of him
they could just be like all right hey
buddy we're not gonna have you running
2024 I'll go okay unless they want to
get rid of them early then they're like
okay here's how we're gonna get you out
early we're going to find documents
you're going to apologize it's gonna be
no big deal and then you're going to
resign maybe what if Jill doesn't like
kamla that's allegedly out there in the
wind and if he steps down it would have
to be Kamala at least at first do you
think it's possible that they that I
don't think they tell them directly
these are all signs that Joe your time's
up that I don't think there's any secret
meeting where they come in and say Joe
don't run but do you what do you what if
Kamal is next in line and they're like
we don't want kamla we want Buddha judge
or Hakeem Jeffries or who has point it's
McCarthy
because yeah if if Joe and Kamal are out
the next in line for the presidency is
the speaker well I mean if John's 20 24
20 24 yeah yeah I don't know I mean I
don't think they need to do this to stop
Joe from running in 2024. they just need
to not give him the IV drugs they've
been giving them you know yeah just let
him fall asleep yeah man don't run him
well there's only so many replicas of
him that they have okay so they might be
running out and they're and they're
they're getting worse they're like
degrading in quality Joe Biden number
five is not doing too well okay sorry
Ian you had a point at 50 000 a month in
rent is complete it's it's not normal
that that can't not I don't know if I
could say that can't be real is it
possible that a apartment buildings yeah
it doesn't seem realities tons of people
have gone through the the rentals in the
area and the highest is six thousand
money average is like three
the IRS would in any other circumstance
would look at this and be like oh yeah
it's illegal yeah I would think so
that's also illegal what so if like Ian
let's say I want to give you a million
dollars
you've got to pay a gift tax on this
there's a bunch of things you can do but
there's like 15 000 is the yearly tax
limit if I pay you a million dollars you
got to pay income tax on it and so you
get you get people who are like how can
I get the money to someone in a way in a
certain way right okay how about I buy a
painting for a million dollars
sit on it for a little while
then claim it's only worth a Dollar sell
it to you for a dollar you can then say
Oh it appreciated to a million dollars
and now you have a million dollar asset
you just have to pay taxes on it I think
what this is evidence uh so so anyway my
point with that is
the IRS tracks for these things because
you can't just give the money to someone
now rental income is still going to have
uh it's going to be taxed so when I
think this is evidence of is not
necessarily that Hunter is trying to
secretly give money you know as like as
a gift I think what he's trying to do is
clean the money the money's dirty so
he's giving his dad 50 Grand a month in
rent so that Joe can claim on his taxes
rental income and then pay the taxes on
it and now it's clear yeah at its face
that's what it looks like if Hunter's
taking money dark money now isn't this
very blatant I mean this is out in the
open
so why why would he think he wouldn't
get caught here because
he already got away with so many things
uh today he's also in court uh demanding
that his uh four-year-old daughter who
he had with a stripper not take his last
name so that's what he's up to today
that doesn't really say you know doesn't
really say the best things about him you
know these kinds of kind of actions
don't scream good father yes
to trying to erase the Biden name from
is this a female
four-year-old daughter he's claiming
that it's a curse
yeah he's like she wouldn't live in
normal yeah he's trying to claim he's
protecting her from the abuse that she
might get for the body name which is he
must have been madly abused I mean if he
thinks that his kid's going to be abused
I would have a feeling that maybe he was
he's playing games with it he just
doesn't want her to get the Biden name
so he's saying I'm trying to help you
don't take the name
but the name actually would help her the
hunter is going to blow the lid on this
stuff in like a decade in the next
decade he already did when somebody
passes away the way Hunter is going to
be coming clean and all this crap now
did you see there's they are so
cold-hearted they hung up stockings for
Christmas and didn't include that
granddaughter
no they included the dog the cat
everybody now I think her name was Navy
I forgot her name her name that's cold
yeah that's the word is the word for is
the word still bastard if it's a girl
that's a good I don't think so I think
it's just a boy but let me double check
a bastet yes and then on top of that I
forget which news Outlet it was they
wrote a headline saying that Joe Biden
has six grandkids he really has seven so
the media so whatever Biden does in his
personal life that's his decision as bad
as it looks but why would the media not
report accurate numbers yeah and the
statistics with fatherless homes are
absolutely shocking when you really
start to look at what happens to a
family when the father is not there it
is absolutely horrendous it is
absolutely horrible the possibilities of
arrest of jail of of murder of assault
of crime Skyrocket up dramatically now
when you have you know a father who's in
politics who's been in politics for so
long he in Washington DC DC for so long
being the career politician that he is
that usually means he has to neglect
being there at home or if he was at home
he was maybe trying to get into some
shower that some kids were into but
that's a separate story I don't want to
get into great detail here but but I
think it's fair to say that Joe Biden
hasn't been the best father as of course
Hunter Biden isn't really showing the
best kind of father figures uh he isn't
really the best role model here in this
particular example as far as I can tell
bastards can be women boys or girls any
child born out of wedlock uh also no
bastard also historically called horsene
that's [ __ ] Sun the full word [ __ ] sun
isn't that incredible horse
I don't want that label that's a vicious
one or son they're like no bastard is
better okay so they they don't how about
snow you know that's that's still from
Game of Thrones yeah that that way it
sounds cool yeah yeah snow is cool yeah
what are the judges like you can't be a
bite which can be a snow
get a name from somewhere
yeah what a what a sad family man it's
like it's like a royal family kind of
they act kind of like that yeah with
that drama on money you know what I was
thinking earlier imagine aliens came to
our planet and landed in America and
they said take me to your leader this is
what would they think
they blow us up yeah they just be like
this isn't worth it like just gone
um there's a story that just came out
maybe that's why they're not visiting
yeah I mean I mean these are ants they
show up like it's us looking at ants
yeah
like who's calling the shots here this
guy no no no no no I don't know I think
if they did show up they would treat us
the way we treat like animals you know
we'd sit back and watch and then be and
you know it's like it's funny because
you ever watch Meerkat Manor no it's
like all the meerkats they go to war
with like the meerkats have war and
tribes and stuff and you know they talk
about the leader and they give them
silly names that's what the aliens are
probably doing they're like the Biden
family is ridiculed by many well I don't
know if the aliens have British accents
or anything like that I forgot who I was
watching over the weekend but it was a
YouTube video that made the argument
that if we do get visited by aliens that
alien would be artificial intelligence
because if you want to have that kind of
long travel if you want to of course
send something why not just send an AI
robot yeah so that's what I think that's
what Elon wants to do with the Tesla bot
everything Elon Musk does is to get to
Mars and I think he knows that it's very
difficult to get out of there with the
radiation all that yeah I agree with
that let's talk about this from the BBC
White House says there are no visitor
logs for Biden's home okay so not only
did he have classified documents stored
there more than we originally thought
Hunter Biden lived there was funneling
money to his dad and we don't know who
showed up if Hunter was living there if
he actually was you know why there's no
visitor log because the list of hookers
would be too long they'd just be like we
got we got her it's all right we got
destiny Laquisha Pink Panther Lotus is a
good stripper name Ian do you know
something candy don't
Agnes yeah she's an old one and how many
of them are like Fang Fang like Russia
you know not Russian or Chinese spies I
guarantee you some of them are probably
spies Joe walks in and Hunter's got like
two Russian women on his arms and he's
sunglasses and he's smoking a joint and
he's like who are these should I see
Scarlet yeah Trixie I don't know spies I
guess
how did they get past security what
security there's no logs there's no
security they're sitting there like
reading the classified documents I hope
champagne you could read
right I want Hunter keep it in my man no
matter cardamom and rosemary how angry
you are Joe like I get Hunter you're
probably pissed off a joke as the way he
treated you throughout your life but you
never would have had a chance to live
like this without him like you would
have had some cheap job that you hated
barely stringing by you wouldn't have
enough money to pull you out of the
gutter when you fell so like be be
thankful to your dad no way dude I I
think I think Joe diddled Hunter for
sure yeah I wouldn't be surprised what
don't say thank him yeah yeah but don't
just put it all on Joe Hunter you've
been sucking off the tit your whole life
man it's your responsibility taking care
of yourself I think Hunter's a bad dude
but I think he got abused by Joe Biden
like you see the Ashley Biden stuff oh
yeah you watch Joe Biden grow children
and sniff them what do you think he was
doing Hunter Biden back at home true
after he lost his daughter and his wife
like what happened to him
I wouldn't be surprised if he took it
all out on Hunter and it's true is it
true that he and Jill Jill had an affair
on her husband with Joe that's a rumor I
can't confirm that but Beau was always
rest in peace to Beau Bai and he was
always the star he was the one that was
supposed to be president now not Joe and
then the problem was Bo Biden was the
good one he was The Good Son Hunter was
always the Dark Horse the you know the
black sheep so that that will mess with
you mentally too on top of I don't know
what other stuff was going on what
happened to the good one
what's a cancer from um well I forgot
how he I think I think they attribute it
to uh his time in Iraq yeah I think Joe
did I wasn't I'm not sure if that is
exactly why but Joe did he thinks that
could have played but then Joe claimed
that he died in Iraq no no yep yep he
did yeah yeah he just he's just gone
no it's not I mean Joe lies about
everything remember when he in the 80s
he plagiarized that entire Irish dude's
life yeah yeah oh yeah every once he was
saying that he was like the top of his
class or something like that like he
left school I worked in the coal mines
yeah he said so much stuff family worked
Beau Biden died in 2015 uh from brain
cancer at the age of 46. and they
thought it was from like extensive
exposure to burn pits and stuff like
that yeah is that what it was uh it
doesn't say doesn't hear we don't know
for sure on that one yeah there's a book
that came out saying it could have been
that nobody knows for sure but Beau
Biden was a star politician I mean he
was next in line
um he was very good military vet yep yep
yep
wow
yeah and now that all I got is Hunter
yeah that's got to be Hunter 2020.
I mean if there's ever going to be a
Redemption Arc it has to be with Hunter
right I would vote for if Hunter was
running for president of the United
States I would vote for him immediately
experience who do you want run in the
country someone who has never lived a
life of of of of of of of excitement of
of just experience or or someone who's
been sheltered in this entire life I
would watch a hunter Biden YouTube
channel and not enjoy it oh that would
be dull but I would not vote for a Biden
any of them yeah no I I think he would
he would be able to deal with serious
problems that Americans are dealing with
because he dealt with them himself yo if
he got the job he'd keep funneling money
to his dad that'd be the whole bit yeah
well that's what they're doing already
like I know that wouldn't change
anything but look I'm disappointed in
you what about fetterman I know
make it all burn down as quickly as
possible make make this shirt
Hunter Biden John fetterman 2024 just
make it all burn down faster
why I look at Hunter Biden's Wikipedia
page and the picture they used for make
him look like Steve Carell in his
awkward office moments like Michael
Michael Scott super awkward big eyes and
then maybe that's just how he looks
Hunter it's all blurry the picture's
blurry like they couldn't just get a
normal picture of him looking you know
charismatic I asked the audience does
this prove Hunter laundered money to Joe
89 say yes
so the challenge with evidence and proof
right proof would be like catching him
whole holding like handing the money I
actually think this is as closest to
proof as you're going to get like him
stating definitively on on a background
check application that he did give this
money to his dad I suppose what would be
better is a bank log showing the
transfer so we know what actually
happened yeah but him stating he did it
is as close to a confession as you're
gonna get yeah I would say it's evidence
not proof I said no on that poll because
it could be Dr uh paper it could be
doctor there's no official stamp on it
um and it could be a lie about the
amount fair point but any evidence could
be doctored any and all of it could be
doctored like you go to you're in trial
because the guy got murdered like here's
the murder weapon it's like maybe
they've fabricated so I would look for
preponderance of evidence to decide
proof if there's enough evidence that I
could say that's probably not doctored
or how about how about this
Hunter Biden said he was paying the
family expenses Hunter Biden says his
dad was was taking half his salary in
the emails he said 10 for the big guy
and then he's giving 10 times the
high-end rent for a rental property that
Joe Biden owns this record should be
looking to this is crazy yeah we're
really close to proof and what I do on
my channel a lot is bring to the bigger
picture you're talking about there are
no logs at his private residence so that
means he can I think he spent 200 days
there he could bring anybody over there
and talk about whatever they're talking
about uh looking at the big picture
don't we have enough to just really as a
country all agree we need to look into
it like is why would we have a bipart
you know a partisan type of battle over
this wouldn't you think anybody on any
political Spectrum would say this
doesn't look right well part of what
I've been thinking as is the great age
of Pardons that we're upon is like okay
the liberal economic order is turning
into the New World Order we need to make
oversee this change and why why do we
hate ourselves for being the pilots of
the Death Star for the last 70 years
like we were basically trying to
militaristically control Earth as United
States like people did horrible horrible
things Henry Kissinger Joe Biden you
name it Donald Trump all these people
with all these secrets and it's like
dude we gotta like make the New World
Order now we need to make a republican
style decentralized statehood across
earth or of the Chinese and the world
economic Forum are going to do it for us
and they're going to make a corporate
communist state
so I want to forgive people that's where
I'm at right now I don't even want to go
after Trump and Biden for the stupid
stuff like we have a bigger deal I I
just want to say there's like a very big
difference between Trump Biden and Klaus
Schwab and all these people like when
these people were murdering children
Trump was firing people on TV like the
worst thing Trump was doing was selling
Pepsi or whatever or being in Home Alone
movies I guess building hotels the
argument is like the worst of the worst
American Military psychos that have been
controlling this liberal economic order
I'm just I don't feel like witch hunting
because we're going to end up pulling
back the curtain realizing we've all
been involved in it we've all been
benefiting from it like it's true that
we have we've been greatly benefiting
from uh from the US Empire the Petro
dollar and all that stuff and uh I'm not
a fan of this idea that the US is the
World Police I kind of like the idea
that we mind our own business but since
what 1913 that's not been the case and
where the Death Star you know
yeah do we do we do we shut it all down
what do we do the world order Death Star
the new world
the New World Order you fear is already
here and they're working with the
Chinese and these internationalists
don't give a damn about the United
States they use that as a vehicle they
use that as a vessel just like they use
China just like they're testing all the
latest Big Brother surveillance
technology there they're going with
their plan of what works out best for
them they have no allegiance to the
United States they're not American
they're internationalists so you got to
understand it from that perspective and
when they talk about a new world order
they're talking about continuing pretty
much the way that the things are but for
a better benefit for them well we would
need like a populist an upright New
World Order like a popular world order
that people actually want not let
corporations top down decided yeah
that's Mega that's how I view Maga what
you just said I wouldn't say the New
World Order just because it rubs people
the wrong way but yeah it's a populist
movement you saw the hold up of the
speaker vote we we haven't seen anything
like that in 100 years International
nationalism
that's what people were jokingly
referring to it as like the idea that
there was a movement of individuals to
strengthen their own countries and their
own borders and respect between
different countries to allow each to do
so
so the media tried mocking the idea but
it was actually quite simple it meant
that someone from the UK was like hey
this is where I live we want to have
these rules that's totally cool that you
live over there and want to have those
rules and then we'll figure out how to
work together and everyone's like yeah
that sounds like a really great idea so
it's an international movement to
restore and strengthen National
boundaries yeah I think Libertarians
have the answer you hear comic Dave
Smith on this show and how based he is
decentralization like you just mentioned
yeah that's the answer to me
yeah they have the United States of
Mexico is already primed we've got the
United States of America we've got
Canada's basically a bunch of provinces
States uh China's a bunch of States like
we're we're really as long as the People
Want it we're prepped to create a
decentralized state across the planet
maybe it's just gonna you know in order
to get these other countries to
recognize the superior way in which our
government works we need to bomb the
crap out of them maybe maybe the hardest
thing we need to do and take their oil
is just you know go there
and then just make them implement this
and then after we make them do it
they'll understand why it's so good they
may resist but it's okay we have bigger
guns than they do well I think really
the key that worked really well in
Afghanistan that's right the key would
be to teach them English and get people
to use English as a primary language if
we all have one language I think that
the best ideas win yeah no no that's a
good idea that's a good idea but but the
other issue is that they might still try
to speak their own language and adhere
to their own cultural tradition so you
beat them no but this is why Hollywood
was so great for the American culture in
the last hundred years is because it
spread English across the planet and
English became the language of business
and and you know when you understand
what American freedom-loving people are
saying it's a lot easier to get on board
the solution to a lot of the world's
problems is individuals not trying to
force their will onto others and as long
as people realize that and respect other
people and respect their property and
their individual sovereignty then and
only then the world will be a better
place but when we have the Cairns when
we have Kyle saying you need to do this
you need to follow this religion or this
edict or this woke Doctrine and you have
to do it or I will get and use extortion
and force with centralized police forces
in order to push my ideology onto you
that right there is the larger problem
of our society and why it is where it is
right now and it takes personal
responsibility individuals being strong
and independent and saying hey I respect
you as an individual respect me uh
standing up for themselves being strong
being able to defend themselves that
truly will lead us out of this but
without your globalist new world order
nightmare that we all are a part of with
that mindset if someone were to
instantiate like a revolution to
statehood like Republican statehood or
something would you I mean the
libertarian mindset's kind of like let
them do it I'm not involved but like
usually you can't revolt against your
system without outside help so like at
what point would you suggest no other
countries always get involved and of
course just like the United States got
involved in Ukraine It's a larger oxy
War but again conflict is usually
routine with that kind of larger idea
this is why I'm saying what you're
describing is one of the problems I'm
describing people trying to force
something on someone else once we get
rid of that Force once we get to that
rid of that extortion just that that
belief system of respecting others there
wouldn't be those kind of confrontations
there wouldn't be those types of
situations what I'm talking about is
kind of utopian but more of just like a
a place where I think we should be going
to as Humanity where we could progress
to a point where we could respect each
other's differences without trying to
bomb or kill each other the current
ethos or the current uh
philosophy I suppose is whoever holds
the biggest stick
because if you don't hold it someone
else will and so the United States is
basically like look our system is better
we got all of these civil rights we've
expanded throughout the years we've done
a great job of things let's just hold
the biggest stick and beat anybody who
disagrees that way we don't got to worry
about them beating a big stick against
us and that's why the you know all the
Cold War was so crucial for these people
that's why the draft Vietnam and all
these countries that's why they used
false flags all that mattered was we
were bigger and more powerful so we
don't got to worry about it they
genuinely believe that by being the
being the Death Star being the Empire
you prevent war and suffering so it's
almost like their attitude is there's
got to be some there's got to be some
suffering some War and then you know
we'll make sure there's not too much of
it
that was The Limited War uh Doctrine
messenger's Doctrine so we would you
know if instead of bombing Moscow if
Russia was going to war in Northern
Vietnam we just fight proxy war in
Vietnam basically what's going on
Ukraine you don't just bomb Moscow
because you're angry that they invaded
Ukraine then Moscow doesn't bomb
Washington DC or Syria total or Libya or
Vietnam yeah it was a mess the the
liberal War Machine went so haywire when
they invaded Iraq and Afghanistan I
think that was when you realized the
first time the second time the second
time was when it was like you have gone
too far you lose the big stick you you
failed whoever's in control of this
system has failed you but I think that
was the first time so they had to try
again they had failed
the well I mean just ethically as a
geopolitical police uh invading the
Middle East like that is an epic failure
like that was I don't know if they
didn't realize that technology was just
so great you can fly bomber planes
around Earth there's no you know yeah
have you seen have you guys seen The
Solar planes that can fly forever yeah
yeah now imagine they put bombs in those
things and they just have them fly
around forever and then it's just like
don't step on it don't you know they
probably already have that yep or the
the the scary thought was the uh you
ever hear of rods from God you know
about this one oh yeah it's uh
satellites carrying giant tungsten rods
they just drop it and it slams into the
Earth
I guess the argument is it's too it's
too uh takes too much energy to put the
rod in space in the first place and then
maintain its orbit by being able to drop
so it just stays up there until they're
ready to drop it yeah they don't release
it if you watch the GI Joe movie that's
what they do oh no I didn't see that
yeah Cobra Commander oh yeah and he
presses the button then he blows up
London
just with a single tungsten Rod yeah it
slams in the whole London just ripples
into the air let me pull up this uh this
next story we got this tweet from Dale
Turner he says the elite flock to Davos
this week on their private jets to
lecture us average folk on why we must
give up our gas powered cars by an
imaginary deadline in order to save the
planet and in the meantime Wyoming
lawmakers proposed ban on electric
vehicle sales
well that well that's something new I
guess what what is it what Wyoming wants
to ban electric cars a group of GOP
Wyoming state lawmakers want to end
electric vehicle sales by 2035 saying
the move will help Safeguard the oil and
gas Industries so I'm sure most of you
all have heard California Oregon and
Washington are moving to ban gas cars I
think California already did goes into
effect 2035. now Wyoming is doing the
opposite could you imagine you're in
Oregon and you're like I'm sorry I'm
gonna drive uh I'm gonna Drive East and
then you get into Wyoming and you're in
your electric car because you don't have
any gas cars and there's no electric
charging stations and you're just like
well what do I do or you're in Wyoming
and you're like I'm gonna go visit the
coast you drive through you take your
gas car you drive an organ no gas
stations
yeah this is uh a thought when you're an
authoritarian like what California is
doing is an authoritarian act it's
government getting in the way of a
private Market demanding that you
transition to a certain Thing by a
certain time what happens is the other
side can play the same game I'm against
it Libertarians have the right idea let
the free market go but
wait wait wait Tim we have freedom of
movements in the future that's not
supposed to happen people have their own
cars that's not supposed to happen we're
supposed to rent cars and share them and
borrow them just like all the companies
that have World economic Forum board
members that are heavily invested in
them we're not supposed to be using cars
and having private property that's not a
part of the UN 2030 vision and not a
part of the vision that Klaus Schwab was
talking about years ago when he was
talking about uh pretty much making sure
that people cannot and will not be
owning cars a lot of major cities are
also making it very difficult to drive
cars New York City is one of them they
set up surveillance cameras everywhere
there's nearly 15 000 surveillance
cameras all throughout New York City
speed cameras everywhere you go over 25
miles an hour you get a ticket right
away build to you there's a lot of
people obfuscating their license plate
in New York City because obviously you
know people people make mistakes it
happens 25 is is not a very high speed
it's a very low speed people make a lot
of mistakes people are being indebted
there's no parking spots every street is
being closed down so you can't even
drive down there drive down most streets
so so we are seeing this 2030 U.N Klaus
Schwab World economic Forum Vision be
implemented very slowly but it's already
happening in New York City it's already
going to be happening in California
where they're banning not just the
electric car not just sorry gas cars
diesel cars lawn mowers
um even golf carts are now being banned
in California which again is just
absolutely insane and crazy and going
towards the vision of what Klaus Schwab
wants for you and not for what anyone
else really wants well look I I can
sympathize with Clash Royale because I'm
you know just imagine you're sitting
there you know you're you're in your
yacht hanging out with all your Rich
buddies and then you look up in the
distance and there's there's some middle
class dude and he's drinking a soda and
you're like what makes him think he's
entitled to the same drinks that I am
and you just desperately want to take
from him everything he owns and then
just put him into indentured servitude I
can totally understand why why they're
mad right or just you know just totally
wipe them off the planet because there's
too many people in this world that's
also another thing that they're also
openly calling for but but making them
super poor uh is is a way of helping you
know make that process go a lot faster
so so these people are are not just
eugenicists they're also utter freaking
Hypocrites there's an estimated 1 100
private jets at Davos this year they
quadrupled their private jet emissions
last year than the previous year before
that so these are individuals who
obviously live by a different set of
rules don't care about the environment
don't give a damn about it this is just
their PR words that they're using to of
course justify their larger takeover of
society which is exactly the Hostile
takeover that we're going through right
now all right then he's not on the boat
watching the guy drink a Coke he's
looking out his window and seeing human
beings in general
is that he's just he's just mad they're
there he's just flying on the private
jet being like there's too much open
land here we need we need to you know
Sheamus and I uh came up with a bit a
while ago about Bill Gates that we never
got around to making because we because
we could put it on YouTube it was
basically a gag about how like Bill
Gates is his day and it's like he's
driving down the street and he like he
pulls into a McDonald's and then he's
like oh I have the Big Mac with a large
fry and don't forget the ketchup and
then when you posted the drive through
the hand in the bag and he looks and he
goes there's no ketchup and so it's like
a series of things throughout the day
where he's he gets minor inconveniences
but like once he he's really angry the
woman knocks in the window it's like oh
forgot your ketchup and gives him more
and then he has an app on his phone we
can't talk about it on YouTube but it
activates a certain thing
and people that wipes out Humanity oh
and so he's like sitting there staring
at his phone like ready to press the
button then she's like wait don't forget
the ketchup and then he's like oh oh
thank you and then he keeps doing it
just like the general idea is that these
people's real anger is not centered in
anything logical it's centered in just
like their their
emotions related to other people like
they just don't like other people so
they make up reasons to justify why
there should be less people
and then Common People Cheer them on I I
said I kind of made my own definition of
whoa because I actually think this is a
part of wokism and I said woke is the
act of allowing an authority outside of
God to Define your morality and what the
the way they're able to get people to
cheer this nonsense on is the climate
gods or their woke or whatever the
climate whatever you want to make it and
you're you're cheering on your own
demise that's how powerful I think this
religion is yeah it's amazing it's like
uh when Disney did the Lemmings
documentary you know the story of that
no apparent like so they made this
documentary in the Lemmings I'll walk
off the cliff and then everyone believes
Lemmings commit ritualistic suicide they
don't apparently what they were doing
was they had like push brooms and stuff
and they were like shoving the animals
off the cliff and beating them and so
they were fleeing to their death and
they were like now filming claim it
happened that's what it feels like a lot
with this world economic Forum stuff
they're destroying your life taking away
everything from you locking things down
then when you're miserable they say are
you miserable it's because of climate
change yeah I mean all these people are
having heart attacks because climate
change yeah yeah suddenly suddenly dying
suddenly from climate change you know
and so yeah you gotta do something about
it
yeah I think it's uh for you know
talking about it for common people I
think uh don't be alarmed I think we
will make it through this uh it might
not be the same future you look at a
generation from now 20 years from now we
might all have neural links two or well
one or two generations from now life's
gonna be fine people are still going to
have friends you might be controlled by
a central being or a government but I
think humans are survivors and life will
be different but in in the end uh it
will look dystopian to us could you
imagine somebody from like the 18th
century looking at what we're doing
right now they would be blown out of
their minds and I think it'll be the
same type of thing generation from now I
think if you took someone from like 1850
in any capacity and transported them
here the first thing they would do was
going would go on a violent Rampage
thinking that it was all satanists and
demons and stuff and that's what we're
that's where we we are now kind of right
we're looking at this stuff I said it's
an anti-god movement I'm still against
it I'm going to speak out against it
don't get me wrong but I think we're
kind of in that same place
I think the future is going to be AI I
like people will eventually cease to
exist in some capacity and ever like
we're already integrating ourselves into
the network with with Twitter and with
these apps and everything and Elon buys
Twitter surprise surprise it's a massive
neural net he also is running neurolink
you combine these two things I mean I
think Elon bought Elon bought Twitter
because he wants to build a neural net
he wants to connect people's brains to
it and Twitter is already the base
component of people injecting their
thoughts into a machine
next you just need to hook it to
people's brains it's there yeah one of
the clips that I also just saw recently
was Elon Musk a couple years ago saying
hey we need to we need to have a serious
conversation about the development of
artificial intelligence here we need to
seriously have some real regulations
here we need to stop doing what we're
doing and he's like no one's listening
and this is just continuing so there's
going to be a lot of implications
because of this and a lot of the most
powerful most Sinister people are at the
head head of these larger technological
advancements there's a reason Klaus
Schwab is calling for the fourth
Industrial Revolution and when he's
calling for that he's calling for of
course using technology for his own
personal benefit screwing everyone else
over and with the advancements I mean
we're seeing the possibility of human
beings living forever and for a certain
group of people to live forever there's
going to be a lot of other people that
are not going to be living forever or
won't be living at all and we have to
understand that there's this larger
trade-off that is being talked about
very seriously right now at the world
economic Forum to be fair though I mean
think about it if they invented the
immortality pill right now and maybe
they already did could they just give it
to every single person
well they're going to say what would
they what how would How would how would
How would how would you guys deal with
that right now let's say some alien came
to you and said here's a bottle of pills
easily replicable and it will make
anyone who ingests the pill one time
biologically immortal like you can still
be hit by a car but you won't age to
death
would you just be like okay everyone can
have it I would spread it yeah yeah I
want everyone to have it I mean what you
would see is centralized power obviously
trying to control it and not let
everybody have it I think but like all
the woke people getting it and all the
yeah the zombies and everything I'm very
much you know I'm against the wokism but
I will support your right to be woke
so
but I think the challenge is there are
some people that
there are some people who believe in
hard work personal responsibility
individual liberty Freedom Etc and there
are some people who think they're
entitled to everything and should take
from you even by force and so it's like
if I'm faced with being like should I
give the immortality pill to the
hard-working Freedom loving
individualist or the woke authoritarian
Psychopaths with guns I probably
wouldn't I'd probably just be like man
that's a tough call isn't it because
look we're not talking about killing
anybody no we're talking about granting
them you know extended or eternal life
so I should say extended the question
would be would you give purified clean
water to all those people the people you
hate as well people you disagree with
your enemies would you if you had the
opportunity to give everyone access to
clean water you wouldn't
yeah I don't think it's that simple I
think if we're looking at say like China
right now
and what they're doing to the uyghurs in
those camps and I'm supposed to be okay
with being like I'm gonna Overlook all
that evil stuff you're doing is give you
some really nice things to help you no I
think the opposite is true I think maybe
at the very least you can be like look
if I've got something you want you got
to stop torturing and raping those women
you agree to that maybe we'll talk but
I'm not going to give you whatever you
know what I mean
I think some tech is that it belongs to
all of us if we can if we can make that
happen yeah but an individual like Jared
Kushner who again very powerful and is
already making statements about possibly
living forever you think he's going to
be sharing that with the yemenis that he
of course brokered a deal with the Saudi
Arabians that he's bombing uh like do
you think he's going to be doing any of
that I don't I don't think that's a
tough question man it is a very tough
question because it's also an ethical
question it's also a question about our
existence here and it kind of changes it
and and it changes also our relationship
with God as well so there's a lot of
deeper philosophical implications here
that I think are worth debating and
talking about on a longer bigger
perspective that's why I don't have an
answer for it let me ask the audience my
first knee-jerk reaction is no
absolutely not you wouldn't share with
everybody I I wouldn't want it to exist
but the problem is it is like a gun and
will the powerful people use it to of
course control Humanity but again that
also makes you less human though you
take one away people's Humanity at the
same time so you're also a part of their
problem so there's a larger conundrum
here that uh yeah maybe maybe that maybe
that's a the gun thing is probably the
better analogy I suppose people have a
right to live maybe if you don't have to
give it to them like we don't just go
around defending people guns yeah
exactly but access to it should be made
available to those who want it yeah let
me know what you guys think in the in
the comments put a one if you don't
think everyone is deserving of
immortality put it too if you think
everyone should just be given no matter
what no matter their political opinion
yeah if the founding fathers were right
in the Constitution today I could see
them putting that in as uh you have the
right to I mean I wouldn't want to live
forever right I mean that takes away
from my Human Experience the night takes
away from all the beautiful moments that
I have here I don't want that the main
thing is it makes you not age so you
could always kill yourself but you just
won't it won't be taken from you I think
is the idea except for these tragic
accidents they're gonna be that's the
problem too is if people think they can
live forever if they're safe they're
going to become obsessive with keeping
their surroundings safe and and soft
Bill Gates would lose his ish if
everyone got a pill to live forever Bill
Gates would be
ah you'd freak out right now and then
start to doubling and tripling down on
all of his efforts that he's already
tripling and doubling but this is what I
think is a large component of it there
was uh like 10 10 no this is 12 years
ago I saw Aubrey DeGray speak in
California you know yeah long hair dude
yeah he's a sentence researcher and he
said that what did he say I'll
paraphrase that could spend a decade
that's this is 12 years ago someone who
was 45 today will live to be 1 000 years
old that's what he said not because
we're going to invent a pill in in the
next 30 Years that will make you live
for a thousand years but because every
year we develop new medical advancements
and our medical advancements progress
faster than a person ages so for
instance someone's 45 in 10 years they
start getting you know bad you know
arteries or whatever well in the 10
years time we've already figured out a
cure for that 10 years later he's got
macular degeneration his hearing we've
already got a cure for that's been 20
years now he's 100 years old and like
you know and he's got joint pains don't
worry we've already figured out how to
restore collagen and so it's just going
to keep happening I actually think
looking at stem cells and stem cell
therapy
yo that stuff's scary crazy we we talked
about this on one of the members only
segments you could actually get stem
cells taken from the umbilical cord or
from your own skin or fat they only got
to take it from babies that was a big
concern back in the day it was like
they're taking you know from aborted
babies and stuff not even they can take
from your own skin or fat your own stem
cells multiply them inject them into
your body the stem cells will seek out
damaged tissues and restore them full
doesn't that when I saw that and watch
this video about it it freaked me out
because I'm like uh won't that just make
you like immortal
because if if you're given Fresh So
cells have a certain number of Divisions
as the telomeres break down
if if our understanding of size is
correct if they're giving you a fresh
fully young baby cell that bonds would
it not just have perfect complete you
know DNA that could replicate or
whatever
sounds too good to be true well there's
already there's already Elites getting
uh blood from young people and athletes
bro just just stem cell therapies eight
thousand bucks you call you call the
company and say you want stem cells and
exosomes fifteen thousand dollars and
they call that I I bet that's what Joe
Biden's getting it's on its way to being
like 80 bucks but that's the question do
do the people that own the world or that
are trying to run the business of the
world do they want
100 300 you know seven billion people to
live for another 6 000 years so that
they can have 800 children each and then
we've got 900 billion people on earth
like I don't think that would start wars
because you're fighting over resources
at that point and cannibalism because
then at that point human bodies are just
mobile food sources yeah I want to jump
to this story from Media Matters
look you want to read that one
it is titled Temple and co-host to make
absurd claims that the government wants
to control your cooking through the
power grid you don't want to know why
that's really funny
so Luke they uh they're ragging on you
here because you mentioned uh and it was
Jamie Michelle from gays against
groomers
and you said for me this is happening in
order to push the kind of digitized
everything to fully have a technocratic
society you need everyone dependent on
technology and if you're able to cut off
that technology you're able to control
people more and cutting people's ability
to heat their own food by simply
clicking a button that could be easily
done with this new policy and I think
that's what they're really doing in my
opinion
Media Matters as it's absurd except in
California they already turned off
people's ability to you to charge their
cars in Colorado people got notices that
they opted into a program
they couldn't change the heating on
their homes they couldn't turn the air
conditioning up so when you see this out
this other media laundering works
you see a thing happen they say you
cannot charge your car because the grid
is overloaded that happened then they
say you cannot turn on your air
conditioning because the grid is
overloaded then we sit here and go now
they want everyone to have only gas
stoves they want to be able to control
the Grid or electric stoves electric
electric stoves and electric cars which
they wanted to put on the grid in
California and which is already
overloaded or diesel cars and they've
already turned off so we're not
speculating at all we're saying hey you
know the thing they already did if they
get this they can do it more and then
mediamatters comes out and says what a
weird conspiracy theory yeah New York
California Washington and uh Maryland uh
Maryland or Massachusetts I I think one
of those two someone has to correct me
on uh in the chat room there all have
quasi-natural gas bands in place and
programs that phase them out over the
next decade the Biden Administration is
of course working closely with the EPA
to make this a federal policy and
obviously with the grid it being
overloaded in many instances this is
obviously going into a a why would they
be doing this other than trying to one
control everyone or to create uh
organized chaos what's the reason here
can someone give me an explanation here
did they give us an explanation here
what Media Matters explaining why this
is happening I don't I bet they didn't I
haven't read this article but uh I'll
I'll you know eat my own words if they
did
because what I said if they ban gas
stoves Nationwide that means rural
people won't have access to a lot of
those uh what I've accessed and a lot of
those people have gas tanks their houses
which would put their cooking on the
grid and that grid can be controlled by
external forces granted you can also get
solar the thing about solar is that even
when you're in a rural area because we
set this up you can get your own gas
tank now you can heat your house now you
can cook your food you don't got to
worry about it
with solar you still have to get
permission from the utilities and the
grid to turn on but theoretically you
could create your own solar internalized
Grid or whatever but um I think yeah
this is this is another step towards
absolute control yeah and now you add
that with smart cities smart grids
walkable cities surveillance cameras
artificial intelligence facial
recognition they're setting up
essentially a prison all around you a
technocratic digital one that there's no
escaping and don't forget the voice of
the robots always got to be British I
don't know why but they do and then like
you're gonna go to your kitchen and
you're gonna go to your refrigerator and
there's gonna be camera on it and you're
gonna try and open it it won't open and
it's gonna be like I'm sorry Luke you're
looking pretty fat and you're gonna be
like I'm hungry no you're not and then
it just doesn't open yeah I mean not
seriously like that but I wouldn't be
surprised if it was like warning your
refrigerator has been turned off due to
excessive use usage you you are over
your allotment of carbon by 47 points or
whatever if you open your fridge your
food will spoil yeah carbon social
credit score through the Central Bank
digital currencies that they're all
talking about implementing through the
world economic Forum in Davos so yeah
it's already here yeah many instances I
imagine it's like we're playing a game
of chess and Luke is saying look they
can move their Knight here and that
would be a problem and then Media
Matters says no no that's not a problem
at all and we're like wait a second you
can make that move so that stuff like
that actually wakes people up I I the
more they do silly stuff like that it
wakes people up look at there's even the
quote from Luke saying oh your Tesla is
also going to be off too yeah it's like
Luke's saying if the Knight gets moved
there that could be a problem and they
say Luke said that the government's
planning on moving his night there and
looks like I didn't say that they are I
mean at least in your quote you didn't
say they are you said I think that this
can happen I mean he's everybody playing
this what you think can happen I don't
think what other people yeah when I
express my opinions I say I'm expressing
my opinions because it's important to do
that because again uh we don't know for
sure what the future is gonna going to
look like but we see through the UN 2030
Vision we see through the great reset
through the build back better we see
through all their talking points their
own articles their own websites them
calling for this essentially having
total control of everyone's life through
technology and whether it's your
refrigerator having Wi-Fi or your
blender or your stove or your car being
dependent on the grid having having you
know smart grids having everything
online leads to a lot of possibilities
of a lot of powerful people using that
power and authority over you to punish
you arbitrarily for whatever they want
did you see Cloud Schwab saying uh the
next thing bad thing will be if the
power grid goes out across the earth I
mean it was just a Twitter video I'm
saying like could you imagine a life
2035 where some false flag or some
organization decides to shut off the
power grid of the entire planet and then
people can't cook they can't drive and
then they start getting These Warnings
on their phone we need you to mobilize
to do X like people are going to be out
of their freaking mind they'll do
whatever the government freaking tell
like we do not want to find ourselves in
that position that is my point and it is
like do the math do the math if you
think it can happen and you've done the
math and it shows that can that it can
no matter how many times people ridicule
yeah we're slowly and surely losing our
rights let's and not only that we're
losing our privacy we're losing our
ability to be secure and we're heading
down one particular road and it is it's
a pretty clear Road we're on a train and
there's another train coming and now
claiming that a train's coming or you're
on the train is is somehow absurd so
whatever yeah there's no dispute that
the government could do what Luke is
talking about so it's interesting that
they don't cover that like that could be
a problem whether it's on purpose or not
if you get everybody on electric devices
then you have more control over them
yeah I mean imagine if Hitler had the
technological advancements that that we
have right now I mean he was already
using IBM he was already using some of
the biggest you know corporations in the
world that we're working with him and
helping him facilitate a larger his
larger paragraphs would you ever watch
Justice League bro no I don't I don't
know I can't remember it's been a long
time since I watched this episode but I
think it was Vandal Savage I'm not sure
but the not all sudden history changes
in the Nazis had won in the future and
it's because a single a single like 20
2000s laptop was sent back to Nazi
Germany there's a really awesome point
to make for a kids show because like to
understand the computational power of a
modern laptop in the hands of a world
power it's like dude the Enigma machine
was this like ultimate device the Nazis
had and it was just like this
rudimentary analog device where they
moved cables around to encode encrypt
messages I I have to imagine that like
Enigma encryption is like dog crap
compared to today's computers and I bet
any modern laptop well I could be wrong
about this but I'd assume a modern
laptop could have could crack the Enigma
encryption so like I watched uh what was
that movie with the with better at
Cumberbatch
yeah that's right I thought it was a
really bad movie by the way but you know
basically he builds this this machine
that goes through every possible you
know uh
a passcode or like citation permutation
to figure out what the Nazi messages are
because the imitation game yeah there
you go and it's like he builds the
computer it's like one of the first
computers it's mechanical and things are
just like spinning
man you take a modern cell phone for 20
bucks yeah and you're gonna like press a
button it's gonna go like decrypting
yeah look like don't you think they'll
be pretty fast again like just around
like literally just brute forcing it
with a laptop eventually I think it
would it wouldn't take too long for it
to to do what to crack Enigma I don't
know enough about Enigma I think Quantum
Computing is insane though because it
can treat numbers as a one and a zero
and it's trying to figure out number
strings okay if if if homie could build
a computer in like 1941 yeah or whenever
it was or 43 to crack an encryption I'm
pretty sure our computers today can
easily crack that encryption I think so
too very very fast Hitler was like the
only reason that he was who he was for
the most part is because of the
technology that he had like telephone uh
I don't know what their phone situations
were like yeah telephone they had video
they had film you know the manipulation
of film and radio got an entire country
of people rallied around him so now
we're just that on the next magnitude of
global yo communication
guys Enigma was like considered
unbreakable it was a it was originally
cracked in like the late 30s by a Polish
dude and then Alan Turing famously
worked on this machine to to crack it I
I just Google searched on quora it says
how long would it take today's computers
to crack the Enigma machine and the sky
Rupert Baines responds
gchq the UK version of NSA did it with a
Raspberry Pi and Legos in 15 seconds
[Laughter]
dude imagine taking one of those things
back to World War II
crazy yeah and for that headline the
other part of it is so Luke says the the
government could make this chess move so
the media matter says don't look at the
move don't look at the move doesn't that
make you even think more like you're
gonna make that move why would you why
would you not acknowledge that that move
could be made the downsides to pushing
everybody to electric and they called me
an Infowars employee I was never an
influors employee you got that wrong
again well they just post fake news I
mean get your facts straight like if
you're gonna call me an employee of a
former company okay let's fact check
that I actually worked for that company
I I did it I got a mess I really like
Media Matters because all they really do
is create like Eclipse clips of the show
it's like
it's like aside from putting the word
absurd in the title I really don't mind
that they're clipping the show and
sharing it with everybody and then they
just run
the uh the advertising what's the text
they were on the uh it's just a
transcript yeah I noticed that articles
like at the bottom it's like
in this article Tim Poole and then I'm
like oh it says they for some reason
they use this picture of me from like 12
years ago what's up with that I'm glad
they brought up this it's hard to find
pictures of you I think Tim I don't
think I'm on the show every single night
piano everybody well other than
screenshots of the show there's the
black and the red background to make it
kind of look like fascists you know what
I love uh this one right here it says
extremist bigots and conspiracy
theorists YouTuber temples 2022 guests
in review and it's like they they try
really hard to smear people like the
things they were saying about Adrienne
Curry it's just like are you what are
you are you nuts like they're just
desperately trying to make everybody
extreme right and I'm pretty sure they
did not put Sheamus on the list and
Sheamus was like I was a co-host of that
show for seven months it was the most
extreme the most bigoted he's like I'm a
conservative Catholic I didn't make the
life one of the problems I feel like
Media Matters is having in a lot of
companies are is that they're looking
for drama where there doesn't have to be
any sometimes you're just talking about
stuff
yeah I think part of it is to make sure
that what they what they're really
afraid of just like when Tim did his
event this weekend they're afraid of you
going out and meeting people and talking
to people of all different political
spectrums so media matter does that and
it's less likely that you're going to
get a leftist on your show right they
don't want to be called of right wing or
you're convert you're talking with all
these radical people so it keeps you in
the Echo chamber I think they're really
that's why I like the Tim the idea you
guys are doing with the coffee shops
like let's get together and talk it can
be apolitical I'm wearing a yaira shirt
from Eric July he has his comic book he
made this character up and that's just
like you guys do your music it's it's um
apolitical they don't they don't want
um Jake euger on this show they wouldn't
want that I know it would be contentious
but they don't want people of different
politics coming on I don't think with
the krakensteins on yeah it was kind of
like it was kind of boring yeah it was
just like we know each other's opinions
and we disagree and it's like okay you
know because a lot of people were like
Tim push back harder and I'm like the
dudes are allowed to have opinions we
disagree with I can't I I can't be like
I think your opinion is wrong it's like
well I think your facts are wrong here's
what I think you're and they're like
well we like these things and I'm like
well you're allowed to like them but
those discussions are important though
so I they don't want that happening but
why do you think that is why they don't
want that happen yeah there's no
speculation at this point well I mean
I'm playing chess too I think they want
everybody funneled online the pandemic
was a great opportunity because you can
control people with algorithms and it's
very hard online to break out of your
algorithm so they don't want people
convert if you talk with somebody else
then you can say Hey Oh I got this
problem too my kids are having this
problem at school and then all of a
sudden how do you do stochastic
terrorism if I know you and I we have a
connection and you're my neighbor or
we've had a couple of discussions and
somebody says oh he's saying all this
radical stuff you can't really make take
that stick I know him I'm not worried
about your thing so the the bit I think
the solution to all of this is
connecting with people I mean right Tim
I mean that's what you're doing with
your culture stuff so I think I I think
so much of this fear the left has is
fake is like it's real fear but the
cause of his fake so I'll give I'll tell
you guys many of you may have heard the
story but we'll talk about it now so uh
not this past weekend the weekend before
I go and skate in DC at Freedom Plaza
nothing happens just literally skate
around hang out apparently some like
woke crew got angry and started sending
messages throughout the skate Community
about how I was brought there by some
pros I wasn't I went there got there
before they were there and it's like of
course I know they are they're famous
Pro skaters and uh so I was like oh wow
look you know these Pro skaters and uh
so apparently it was a big deal and
their messages being sent around I'm
getting texts from like pros they're
like yo like it's a lot of flat going on
like people are mad that you were there
and I'm like nobody said anything to me
they were posting in forums lies saying
like everybody stand on the other side
of the parkway so I was sitting
alongside 15 other people we were
chilling there's a dog and dog pissed in
the ground and we were like we're out
skating and these things happen
and so I'm like my guys it's not real we
go skate all over the place you know
what I own the only thing I see
we went to the opening the hair to
Hagerstown Skate Park Maryland fist
bumps high fives people were like whoa
oh crap yo Tim cool to see you here
let's let's Skate we went up to one
indoor skate park in Altoona
Pennsylvania and we I walk in and what
do I hear they're coming for your income
tax and I'm like these guys watching I
can verify I was there that day it was
cool yeah yeah we hung out and the dudes
were like oh wow cool cool to see you
and they were like dude skateboarders
are like anti-establishment people
but all of a sudden now I got these
industry people being like bro we're
taking a lot of heat like people are
really freaking out about what's going
on and I said no they aren't dude this
is not true and they were like well look
man like it's getting bad and then I
said I'm gonna go back on Saturday I'm
gonna tell everybody to be there and I'm
telling you nothing's gonna happen and
what happened a bunch of people showed
up we skated we hung out people took
pictures I gave out skateboards locals
gave me fist bumps
and we had a good time then someone told
us about this uh little spot called the
Big Board in DC that defied the
lockdowns and they were like you should
go eat there because they told you know
mural Bowser to Fu when she was trying
to lock everything down and then so then
I said to everybody okay that's where
we're going and we packed the place it
was just like every table filled this
whole venue that's what it's all about
not only did we prove that the fear
these people in skateboarding had over
oh no everyone's going to be mad you're
there oh we're not true never happened
it was a lie to scare you into not
speaking up and being yourself and I had
no problem showing up skating around and
bringing Taylor Silverman and Taylor of
course is the one who called out
biological males competing against
females against her and she gets tons of
threats and hate and we announce will be
in a Public Square
by ourselves well you know with our fans
or whatever and our friends but like
skating around any one of these whack
jobs could have come up to us and done
anything they wanted nothing happened
not a single hater showed up no violence
nothing but happiness and high fives and
then
with that Gathering and people met each
other and talked to each other hung out
and laughed and had a good time we also
told everybody to go and hang out at the
Big Board in DC
to support businesses that stood up for
what they believed in creating nothing
but massive positivity without a modicum
of hate or resistance people need to
stop believing the lies the woke people
are like we'll cancel you what's the
worst that's going to happen what's the
worst gonna happen yeah yeah that's why
I want to know what the money is behind
groups like antifa because I don't think
it's organic I don't think it's really
there I think you have to have some type
of funding or push to get you don't
think so I don't think you need funding
to get a bunch of unemployed whack jobs
to go be whack jobs you know you need
some because organizational power is
tough but it shows you that if there's
nothing to Target there's nothing to
Target if I announced we were doing a
legitimate event speakers tents and
everything they could stop that they'd
call the city they'd make complaints but
when I said I'm just going to be
standing there not a single hater showed
up not a single complaint was made
we skated around
did some tricks I did a kind of a bunk
forward flip because it was like windy
and cold someone filmed it so they put
up a video on Instagram actually let me
shout the dude on Instagram I think I
have it on my phone that's pretty cool
were you still gonna do a skate Channel
I remember we talked about it
we're working on it let me uh well it
just it just disappeared do you have
this kind of feeling of of community uh
where you're from do you do and do you
think there's a way to help facilitate
all that
um I think everybody has their own
talents so where I'm from I don't really
feel the I don't really feel it much
anywhere I mean there's not many people
working towards that solution
um I want to do a shout out to uh black
Pegasus who's A hip-hop artist out of
Colorado
this Christmas he went around to
Christmas malls and he's been practicing
freestyling him and his partner partner
Don so they walk up to random people
and they just say hey how you doing you
wanna of candy cane they take a candy
cane out there's like a little five
dollar bill on it and then they say give
me three words I'm gonna wrap a song for
you just out of the blue and then they
wrap a song for them and then sometimes
they give them like a stack of ones or
something like that but that's
connecting to people completely
apolitical but I think I believe
everybody has their own talent to do
that maybe you so maybe you play music
whatever that is that's the answer to me
to break away from from what we're
seeing right the ballistic boy on
Instagram Everybody follow the ballistic
boy he produced a video from the from
the quote unquote unevent we did and
there's just happy people standing
around taking pictures people skating
and doing tricks fist bumps no hate and
that that was the privilege point that I
could show up in public with a week's
lead time everybody can know nothing
bad's gonna happen I got mixed feelings
about it because it feels like going
into a bear's den and then standing
there and being like see the bear didn't
attack me I'm fine but like it's not I
don't think it's sustainable what better
though that's the point there was no
bear there you're calling it a bear's
den and I'm like bro we're gonna go in
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna turn the flashlight and show
you there's not a break not
embarrassment but it's like saying hey
all bears I'm gonna be here on this time
in this day they're not bears and you
shouldn't live I mean some of them
pretty chunky but they don't move like
Bears okay and what happens can a
squirrel attack you and bite you all
these things yes I give you baby do you
want to you know run into a a cave full
of angry rabbit squirrels you don't but
you know what happens when you when you
yell around squirrels they run away yeah
right I get it's just that I don't know
if it's it's sustainable to dox yourself
and other people a week beforehand to
have a million people providing our
assassination coordinates yeah exactly
like if we did that every week for 10
years I would imagine one of those weeks
something bad could it's just not a
sustainable price maybe but when we were
in Nashville and we wanted to go play at
John Rich's Honky Tonk and the death
threats came in they said we can't do it
and then I said I don't care I'll do it
anyway nothing's gonna happen and they
were like but there are people here if
something does happen there's kids we
could get hurt I said okay fine you know
it's like your Venue I did this to prove
that point these people are all talk all
bark no bite I used to notice that in La
too like I was like I'm tired of this
people they would say in L.A people are
fake and I knew they weren't so I had to
get through these people I just decided
let's get rid of the pretense go
straight eye contact eye contact every
human I would meet I would talk to them
like this as if they were my best friend
and people would respond as if they were
my best friend when you give them that
energy so I think you can get through to
every human it was a hundred percent it
would work 100 of the time and then but
what I realized is you can't be friends
with everybody you got about 60 people
after that it starts to drive you insane
so you shouldn't Live Your Life In Fear
like I refuse to do that and you know
you talked about how Tim's you know
docson comes up I mean people know where
we live right the address here has been
leaked many times but you know we've
been swatted many times so they already
know so what what's stopping them from
from doing anything I mean it's really
based on your approach as a human being
and how you interact and what you bring
into your own life and I just refuse to
be in that kind of fear mindset myself I
agree I don't want to live in fear I
don't but I don't think it just it
doesn't mean if you decide not to do
certain things it doesn't mean that
you're it's because you're afraid or a
coward like some things technically or
mathematically are not a good function
that you want to be involved with yeah
it doesn't mean that you're afraid
you're just doing the math looking at
the odds looking at the risk but if they
could get you there they could get you
here right because they know I'll give
you an example though of Tim you know
showing the boundaries remember when
Andy know in my opinion unnecessarily
put himself Undercover the second time
he had already came out with his book on
antifa that he went undercover again and
you guys covered it remember and Tim I
believe and I agreed with this said that
was an unnecessary risk so I think you
know you guys did the risk I think you
have a great point you got to look at
the risk reward I don't think Tim's
gonna do it every week but uh the
courage you've got to show some courage
I think for everybody watching this this
isn't just for Tim or Ian or anybody
else we've all got to have courage
um you know the history of this country
is founded on people with courage I mean
they what tried to tax T three cents you
know a pound of tea and they went nuts I
don't want you know I want peacefulness
but you have to have courage to stand up
for and courage can be just like what
we're doing not just talking I respect
and you know tremendously and I think
what he did was tremendously Brave yeah
I just felt that like the risk versus
reward was extremely high risk with
really low reward it was a local Fringe
antifa meeting it wasn't a big prominent
one it was like a handful of just
lunatics and then he went right into the
middle of their group
what we were doing was going to a place
I had already been
and had no issues at telling my friends
to show up there we can advance
and then showing up
and nothing happened I didn't say like
I'm gonna go find you know antifa's
house and go inside of it and uh you
know and we talked you know Andy and I
talked about it I apologize for being
crass and everything but I still think
it was unnecessary risk I respect him
wanting to cover the stuff and get more
information I do I understand it but we
were basically saying hey we skate we're
allowed to be here I live here I live in
this area I'm gonna skate here and I
proved that a lot of this is just
nonsense
and I gotta be honest I'm willing to bet
if Andy Noe announced he was going to be
at Freedom Plaza nobody would have shown
up to harass him it would not have
happened
yeah it does seem like it's more about
the events it's more about the uh like
the intentions that are being blockaded
and and stressed not the people
themselves it's almost irrelevant to
what people are why do you think it was
different with the Nashville show where
there was someone else owned a venue oh
so it's still gone so they they put
pressure on the venue owners or whoever
the business is well John Rich owned it
and oh it was his okay it was his place
and he said why don't we go Jam I said
let's do it and we announced it and then
they got some suspicious calls a guy
showed up some other stuff happened and
he was like we can't do it it's it's
this this is the problem they can use
this as an attack Vector they can't use
it against me right it might work
against your traditional run-of-the-mill
person who's like look
I can't risk the security stuff my
attitude is like dude
I'm not the one
you know when when Nancy goes around
throwing Molotov cocktails I'm throwing
it through it
that's not on me and you can't put that
on me if I'm going to exist and live in
the space I will do it and if a crazy
person is crazy that's something for the
government for the police to deal with
and then to the extent that we have to
defend ourselves we will too so when we
open our Cafe I'm not going to put up
signs in the window saying please don't
hurt us I'm going to put up signs in the
window saying America First yeah don't
tread on me and everyone's gonna know
exactly who we are and what we believe
and maybe they'll want to say nasty
things about us don't know don't care
I'm not no one no external factor is
going to come in and look
I didn't run a business during the
lockdowns but I absolutely would have
been one of the businesses saying Fu to
the machine just like the big board did
in in DC shout out to them again because
that's the story I guess they said no
way we're not shutting down I've done
the same thing and see here's the thing
it's easy for me to say because we've
got we've got funds
for these smaller businesses that
actually did it that shows you who's got
balls these guys do
uh big board by the way open till
midnight if you guys want to get in
there and get something if you're in DC
that's where you should be eating
because I gotta the wings were good I
got the Kung Pao Wings it was really
good yeah it was really really good
actually I'm hungry again
this is like once as you get more famous
as an Entertainer your your role becomes
like Annie knows situation he used to be
able to go under under cover because no
one knew who he was now he's he's
serving a different function but you're
right that we need to be brave but like
I used to do Gatherings and meetups and
events out in the open we'd all be like
hey on the 7th of July we're all going
to meet in Washington Square Park we get
like 50 people would go we don't have
cameras with I never thought in my mind
like danger that never crossed my mind
but I was an unknown person at that time
I don't know if it matters how famous
you are
um I don't know I was thinking as well
it's also like if they know like Fox
News is going to be there if they know
CNN's going to be there then they're
more likely to go out and and do these
things in protests and create like
counter protests and everything like
that but if it's just Tim going to go
hang out I don't think that they're
gonna you know they're not gonna show up
there's nothing to do we announced uh
you know Phil was an to be there Libby
Evans was there Taylor silver was there
like she moved didn't she did she move
from New York I think I saw a article
because every time she comes on I'm like
how are you in New York with you know
things are getting serious where did she
move to again I don't I don't know okay
but uh yeah she Libby went went real
world wow no I think the way we
described it was if you create an event
they'll attack the venue they'll use the
government against you if you just make
it an event there's literally nothing
they can do right because if they show
up to protest they'll be like oh you you
guys are gonna bring us here I'll go
skate across the street yeah protest
what exactly you might be on to
something do you think that would work
in Portland yes wow you mind me you
might be onto something Portland well I
mean that's isn't that the heart or
wherever the real City this is basically
what they do yeah they March around
randomly totally and so that what are
the cops gonna do you can't stand here
okay we'll stand over there yeah so
obviously though like Patriot pair Mark
Patriot prayer marches around they fight
with them you know but my thing is like
I didn't set up an event to protest
anything yeah just declare anything
exactly I'm going to be here and I'm
going to assert cultural presence in the
space and then we gave out like 30 or
some odd boards and uh I told I told
these guys I will flood the DC Metro
with a thousand free skateboards I will
give every single little kid in this in
this metro area a free skateboard every
skating kid and then every little kid
will be riding around on a step on step
and find out board and all the people
can cry about it and then you know we
can do because we're opening this Cafe
second floor is going to be uh skate and
game shop we will sell our boards at
dirt prices
cost
and you know I know a lot of people are
you know that's bad for other shops or
whatever yeah but the other shops are
woke
there's like there's like one or two
other shops and I don't hear good things
about them
and so I'm like well you know what if
these are the people who ride for these
shops
that I hope they go to business
and that's competition baby you get woke
you go broke I'll open up my shop we'll
sell all of our stuff as dirt cheap as
possible
and then let's see how long these well
these Workshops can last true let's
compete are you gonna sell wheels and
trucks too oh of course yeah everything
well we're not going to make our own
making our own wheels is actually pretty
easy because it's all like you find a
company that does urethane and then you
get it special formula formula and uh
and and labeling skate decks are
relatively similar you find a company
you find the shape and the sizes you
want then you get the graphics put on
them
so we'll have all our own stuff but
we'll probably just sell your your
typical skate stuff and we'll sell it
for dirt we'll sell it at cost
we'll pass those savings on to the
regular people now Distributors are
going to get mad a lot of these
warehouses might refuse a service being
like no because you're gonna You're
Gonna Hurt our other business
because if shops go out of business
because they're only buying for you then
we lose sales and things like that I've
seen it happen yeah what I noticed that
when you look at around at stores you'll
never see like well I can't say never
but like a discrepancy in the cost of an
item from Target to Walmart to Mom and
Pop like not that much or maybe I'm
wrong about that but are there like
cabals that are price fixing behind the
scenes like Hasbro it's about price
fixing it's like if there are 10 skate
shops in one area
and one of them goes to the warehouse
and you know and they're they're all
buying from the same Distributors a big
Warehouse that has everything and then
they sell to the shops they might not do
it the same way anymore now with the
internet and Amazon and all this stuff
but if one of these shops starts selling
boards for a dollar over cost compared
to like five dollars over cost the other
shops do the other shops start being
unable to compete start buying less from
the warehouse complain to the warehouse
being like yeah this one Shop's just
gutting us then they'll say we cut off
one shop or we lose five customers
it's not necessarily price fixing but I
don't know it might be illegal I've
heard stories you know
but uh I'm down let's see what we can do
I think that's the answer what you're
doing right there yeah it's literally
like just making you know this the
Marxist so I say everything's politics
well then let's make things not politics
let's do things that are in politics or
let's make music that isn't politics
music you know or orders like you're
gonna come to a skate shop with a big
old Gadsden flag flying above it
marxists win if everything's politics
I'll put it this way to be that way true
we'll have a big old Gadsden flag on our
skate shop but when you walk through
those doors underneath that Gadsden flag
you're going to get a premium quality
pro skateboard gear
for cheaper good coffee too with coffee
yeah you get a free coffee with every
board yeah coffee heavy cream included
because we're keto yep but why would why
would any mother father or skater be
like I'd rather go to that woke skate
shop where everything's 50 more
expensive because I'm woke now they're
gonna be like look man dude the board's
aboard I can't afford it true and then
when they're riding around on a step on
step and find out board and they're woke
friends why are you riding Tim pulls
borlik because it costs 20 bucks dude
and it's pro quality yeah Shaq did a
very similar thing with sneakers that's
right because he talked about how a
mother came to him and was complaining
about how his sneakers were I think a
hundred dollars or 150 and that was
unaffordable so he then uh worked with
um I forgot what company he worked with
but he made his own shoe line and he
made sneakers twenty dollars and then he
was able to get a huge chunk of the
market and make a lot of people happy
and was able to sell a lot more shoes
than a lot of the other competitors that
he was going up against because he
decided to price them out fairly because
a lot of the times when you're paying
for a product you're paying for The
Branding you're paying for the marketing
you're paying for all the other bull
crap associated with it which is now
associated with the ESG social credit
score system which is meant to
indoctrinate you which is meant to of
course divide you and to of course
eventually conquer you but if you're
able to do the opposite of that let's do
it I'm in you know I don't have Disney
anymore oh Stefan Mulberry also did a I
want to shout him out because he was
around where I grew up he was a
basketball player he also did a very
similar thing he made uh his own
sneakers his own clothing line at a very
Avail affordable price compared to his
competitors so shouts out to Stefan
Wildberry
um awesome guy I don't have uh Disney
anymore because ever since the uyghur
Muslim Scandal that happened I said I
would never sign it back up so I had
already had a year subscription it
lapsed
but the thing is I don't I don't expect
people to cancel their Netflix their HBO
or whatever because people want
entertainment it's a normal thing people
buy we just need to create something to
compete with it so that people are like
I'd rather not watch that it is very
difficult it is very easy to open a
skate shop relative to starting a global
Media company with you know subscription
service to compute the likes of the 30
million or whatever Netflix subscribers
but that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm talking about doing so I think
the brick and mortar shop is
probably the faster route towards
building culture
you know we obviously with cast of
Castle tales in the inverted World pop
culture crisis we here at timcast are
working on creating media products it's
hard to do yeah it's it's hard to do
because
you know
with an online product let's say pop
culture crisis we need more we want we
want more people to watch that talk
about pop culture and stuff
and have that influence exist but this
is an Internet space meaning there's no
location you literally have to create
the audience with a physical location
you've got natural flow so for the
building we have now we open a coffee
shop revenue is basically guaranteed we
can afford to operate it and we can make
just enough money to keep it running
skate shop and everything as well and
then we can easily make more and keep
doing it replicate it all over the
country maybe even in other countries
and then have a space where when you
walk in to buy a coffee you look on the
TV and what do you see playing as you're
ordering a coffee it's lucrutkowski
ranting about Klaus Schwab imagine that
imagine there were a thousand coffee
shops and they were like as ubiquitous
as Starbucks but instead of going in and
seeing CNN on TV you see Stephen Crowder
or stick sex and Hammer or Viva and
Barnes or middlemaga
yeah and then regular customers aren't
gonna they're gonna walk in and be like
oh what's this they're gonna be sipping
their coffee back oh that's cool and
that's how we gain access for more
people and more cultural spaces that's
the plan man yeah so maybe we'll
franchise it maybe that'll be the plan
and also competitions just like uh
skateboarding competition Stefan
Mulberry used to have basketball
competitions in Coney Island that I used
to play in and he would get the funds
from a lot of his uh bigger kind of
companies than the cheaper sneakers he
would kind of give out there and then
pay for this uh competition pay for this
larger Festival you get you got free
sneakers you got free jerseys and he
would always come through the community
and give a lot of the stuff out and I
remember uh being a young kid in in
Brooklyn at the time being a part of
that thinking how cool that that someone
in the NBA is coming here and giving
back to the community uh more than all
these other people who of course
essentially sell out and forget where
they came from so uh uh you know Stefan
warberry was awesome shout out to Monica
I want to shout him out again because of
the impact he had on me playing
basketball in New York City
yeah I didn't know you played Hoops yeah
I I love basketball and that was a big
part of my life when I was very young
um and uh yeah it's it's a great way of
staying out of trouble especially in New
York City
we got to do we got to do man we gotta
build culture I was uh we were talking
about a little bit before the show Elon
Musk or I think even during the show
and I hung out at a party with a bunch
of people in Elon Musk Circle and they
all believe that technology is the
solution of the culture war and I'm like
that's like saying if we're going to win
this War I need to buy a lot of land
because everybody knows whoever controls
the land wins the war so by owning the
land it's like okay dude they're gonna
walk onto your lane with guns because
you have no people on the land exactly
the challenge is getting the land and
people on the land so they're not
they're not fully there they're buying
the land isn't going to give you the
battlefield but that's that's how they
feel so to a certain extent it obviously
does benefit you know like Elon Musk
buying Twitter did a lot of really
important things but they genuinely the
all these guys are like yeah once we
control Tech then we're gonna it's like
maybe a little bit Yeah like you can
increase awareness and I look at it like
if anybody plays the Starcraft type of
games you can increase your land mass
like Tim's talking about but you need to
have people on it for it to really mean
something to be able to protect it so I
think that helps but that's not the full
full answer Elon Musk is great in the
area of business and engineering and all
that when it comes to the solutions to
these issues I think he's an infant I
think morally he's struggling we were
talking about the Twitter files releases
is anybody watching the Twitter file
anybody reading those I'm reading them
but no it's not reaching anybody and I
think he's struggling look man
you know people get people got mad
because I was you know Luke and I were
eating dinner and I see that one of the
Twitter file stories comes out Saturday
at like 6 p.m and then I was like are
you nuts dude not only is it a Saturday
when traffic is at an all-time low for
the week but it's dinner time on
Saturday I mean like Saturday mornings
and maybe people are waking up and they
might check their phone Friday evening
is is rough because everyone's leaving
work and going to the bar Saturday
afternoon you're done and I'm like did
they intentionally kill this story by
doing so now they were they keep doing
the stupid thing where they're like you
go to slow roll the stories you gotta
like with with the with the um Snowden
Stuff Glenn Greenwald and poitress
they're like I don't know whose idea it
was but they were like slowly released
the story is to maximize reach and I'm
like no what happens is you put out
mediocre story mediocre story mediocre
story we're done we're tired not
interested
with the Twitter files they should have
released like 10 stories all at once
they should have put the files in a
repository and released them and let the
entire Community have access
instead I guess Twitter files came out
this morning nope nobody tweeted it
nobody shared it are you serious I
didn't even I didn't even know 15 the
last one I saw was 14. oh yeah yeah it
was uh lee Fang oh my God yeah he
started the Twitter files thread uh 10
hours ago wow so they should have just
dropped all the files all at once like
Wikileaks yeah if if I had access to the
Twitter files and I released them like
how Elon did like everybody would be
destroying me right they'd be like what
are you doing like who cares and you're
releasing them on a Saturday this is a
big story too this is about
um the pharmaceutical industry lobbying
big Tech to ban people who are anti-vaxx
wow or not even or calling for cheaper
medicines right yeah and so uh this this
dropped from the Twitter files and uh
nobody talked about it
here's what should have happened he
should have dumped all Communications
because the other issue is Elon Musk is
hoping these journalists can find the
stories
big mistake yeah and that might be
fantastic but
there's probably something in the
Twitter files I'll give you an example
if I was talking to somebody and said
you know let's say the email says
something like this
hey this is uh Tim from over at timcast
I was wondering if you can give me uh an
update on the Nolly foot front side
crooked grind we're looking at John uh
hitting those slappies and we wanted to
get something a bit more substantive so
we needed maybe like uh you know big
heel back tail big big flip out
Matt Toby's gonna look at that email and
be like I have no idea what this is and
he's going to ignore it
now anybody who skates is going to be
like they're filming Escape video those
are some sick tricks a big heel back
tail that's crazy like we're talking
about big inward heal man we're not
talking about front side but my point is
jargon esoteric language someone might
say something like an acronym one of the
pharmaceutical guys might be like yo
we've gotta we've got a jn3 uh you know
out of our backlog files and this is
this is pretty serious and he's going to
be like I don't know what that is and
then somebody who knows security might
mean this was a Russian hacker who broke
in and stole people's medical files or
something who knows if Elon were to take
all the emails and just dump them out
and be like
there you go everybody you'd have
decentralized investigation right you'd
have people in the medical industry
being like whoa whoa whoa look at this
instead what you get are journalists who
are not experts in any of this
trying to find the social sounding
stories to publish hey look
pharmaceutical companies lobbied to ban
content okay I'm not surprised by that
but what about the pharmaceutical
companies talking in emails with other
Executives about
how adverse effects monetary policy
pertaining to the vaccines things that a
Layman could not understand
the journalists are taking a political
angle how were they colluding with each
other
a person who's into medical or
pharmaceutical might be like how were
they preparing to sell this and what
were they saying about the the rn6 codes
you know so I'm making it up but let's
say like there's an FDA Administrative
Code that gets released with every
product these journals won't even know
what to look for
instead we get limited access put out on
terrible times and nobody even knows
what's happening we need 4chan to to
have the files now no actually not even
a joke
I'm going to take it a little further I
think the Twitter files are a psyop this
is Elon Musk is not he's I mean he might
be kind of a novice in a way with the
media side of stuff but he's not stupid
and we know there's still FBI and CIA X
you know you know agents are there at
Twitter right now
um Dr Shiva irude
said that Elon Musk was asked point
blank is the portal still open between
the government and Twitter and he said
I'll look into it
so it's to me and then Jim Baker you
probably remember that Jim Baker was
filtering the files when you look at all
the Twitter files at the end of each
thread
they say we didn't do the searching some
a Twitter lawyer did the search they're
not even able to search through the data
it to me you add all of it up it's
almost like
Elon and this is complete speculation
this is play in chess Elon remember he
was held up on the deal for a while in
in court before he said okay I'm gonna
buy it
what if Elon was like I I gotta buy it
but I want people to trust me
so let me go ahead I gotta release some
information for people to buy into me so
you release some information you release
it on odd hours you slow roll it now
nobody I didn't even know I've been
following this stuff I didn't even know
it was released so now you've built some
trust with the radical people who are
paying attention there's no Normie
around Thanksgiving I think it was or or
Christmas I was asking normies anytime I
saw a normie that you know we're just
chilling somewhere I was like have you
ever heard of the Twitter files not one
person told me they knew anything I was
like what do you think of Elon Musk
they're like I hate him like why do you
they don't even know him it's a psyop to
in my opinion affect those who are
paying attention
to gain trust and
um to buy in and elon's I think it's
paying off how many people do you see on
the right you know kind of bigging him
up and I I think Elon Musk has been a
fraud so far it could change but when it
comes to his first amendment stance and
the Twitter files this is a debacle and
uh to add to your point maybe that's why
the stories get released on Friday and
Saturday nights to make sure they don't
actually have any real press impact Elon
that's the pr 101 yeah the questions out
there Elon tell us why they're released
at this time why haven't you released
all the files now why are the lawyers
doing the searching well it could be to
try to bring people in for when traffic
is low on Twitter in order to build up
advertisers I mean and then let's be
honest here I think Elon Musk lost uh
more money than anyone else in recorded
history
on this particular deal and he he you
know lost a lot he wagered a lot too
what he's doing with it is he going to
be doing the hive mind is he going to be
doing the X app the everything WhatsApp
WeChat app I mean time will only tell
I'm still waiting for the fauci files
and then I'm going to make my decision
after that to to discern what is going
on here but so far hey we did get a lot
of crazy information especially about
the FBI essentially running Twitter
essentially running social media and
deciding who has a voice and not that's
huge having those receipts I mean that's
big right there so what's happening
behind the scenes I don't know but uh I
want to give him a little bit more of
the benefit of the doubt myself I felt
like the it was very cringe the way
things happened and I'm going to be
really critical about it calling it the
Twitter files it's like we're a little
group look how cool we are what's the
name that you would give him you don't
need to name it just release the data
yeah what the hell I agree and then it
gives it to like particular journalists
they're like I'm the one with the power
now and you're like I can't stand it
always hated it what also prevents
connecting the dots because if the
general public had it we could connect
the dots between this person and that
person this document but when you have
it in in so many separate hands it's
it's very hard to get the bigger kind of
story here or even the whole truth here
yeah it's all it's only
um I do want to give Elon credit because
I think the information is true and I
think it's good but imagine if you have
the j6 footage and I can't search
through it I have to ask your lawyer to
search through it we want all the
footage and just let us search through
it how we want
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only uncensored show coming up for you
and uh you know I'll tell you the
reasons why we started doing the members
segments in the website is because in in
2020
Revenue was Bonkers it was amazing it
was a crazy year for everybody in terms
of uh politics everybody was locked up
all they could do was listen to podcasts
January is always our apocalyptic like
budgets are in the gutter and we just
like you don't make money on Advertising
so I was like that's not sustainable we
need to create something different and
obviously a lot of podcasts had like
subscription-based stuff so that's what
we decided to launch so I will just tell
you guys right now it is because of your
memberships we make it through January
and February then ads come in and
supplement but the majority of what
operates uh runs this company is
timcast.com memberships that is the bulk
so we uh we rely on your support if you
believe in what we're doing and we
really do appreciate it that's why we do
those uncensored segments and we're
trying to we're trying to make more and
I think what we're going to do for the
the space we're building is we're going
to create like a semi-vip private
private area where it's like if you're a
member of timcast.com and you show up
you can like come hang out in this like
I'm thinking like maybe Ian's Crystal
Cove will be that little special little
spot but then we're going to have a top
floor VIP private social club which will
be probably more expensive something
like five grand per year which is I know
it's a lot of money for a lot of people
Social Clubs typically cost a lot more
than that but the idea is there's free
drinks free food and networking for
people who are working on stuff and
that's kind of the point and uh and then
you know that's the plan we'll see how
it goes maybe we can't even do it
because the reality is like the reason
we settle on that number is because you
got to hire staff for it you've got to
have like the utilities paid you've got
to be able to do food and everything and
then we're going through it and we're
like it actually might not even be
possible at that number it might have to
just be like a pay admission thing where
it's like if you come and you want to
come in you pay one time or something
but we'll figure it out
let's read some super chats what do we
got
all right James orenthal Nguyen says
shout out to supreme leader beanie met
you at gourmelts last month and brought
my kids to meet you at Freedom Plaza
thanks for inspiring next generation of
righteous culture Warriors respect good
to hear from you dude glad to see you at
Freedom Plaza that was a lot of fun glad
to meet uh get to meet your kids who you
talked about so uh really appreciate it
Gore meltz is a pretty cool place too we
got to do it we got to do an event there
we were planning on doing an event with
gourmelts I don't wanna I don't want to
leave Matt Strickland hanging we're big
fans but we wanted to do a big event
over at gourmelts in Virginia because
this is a guy who not only is a place of
amazing food but they they also defied
the lockdowns and said it's
unconstitutional F off so we got to
figure something out man and I'm talking
to him about uh getting rid of the seed
oils and doing all butter and lard I've
been having a big conversation with them
about that and he's like I'm almost
there so uh yeah gourmel it's awesome
business that's being punished by the
state of Virginia they took away a big
part of their licensing yeah because
they didn't comply with with the
lockdowns which is absolutely really
insane so yeah check out gourmelts if
you're in the Virginia area support them
all right Logan Culver says Tim you're
not wearing your whoop strap anymore are
they worth the price or what's up with
them well I'll give you my thoughts uh
at a certain point I just didn't feel
like I was getting anything from it
it was it tracks like my heart rate but
I got the sleep eight bed which is like
it's so awesome you guys know about this
league Luke turned me on to it yeah oh
yeah it is a bed that has a little air
conditioning like as a temperature
control unit you put distilled water in
it little hydrogen peroxide and it can
warm or cool each side of the bed so
some days I'm feeling like I gotta I'm
hot it's like it's like a hot day or
whatever and I want a cold bed some days
it's freezing you crank it all the way
up oh it's amazing but it also tracks
your your heart rate heart rate
variability and stuff like that so I
didn't really need the whoop anymore and
also I couldn't find any consistency
with what the whoop was tracking like
you know I stopped you know I started
doing this routine nothing changed I do
this routine nothing changes and
ultimately I was just like okay
literally nothing is changing on the
day-to-day like when I don't exercise
when I do exercise I'm like I can't I
can't figure it out so there's no point
in wearing it yeah I mean for me um I I
have seen a correlation and I'm always
trying something new and something crazy
especially in the world of health and it
does track uh the reaction to it but
again uh make sure you save your own
data and you use anonymous emails with
there's many different things don't just
give up your information to all these
private companies I will add one thing
whenever I would drink any amount of
beer the next day the recovery would be
in the gutter yeah like I'm like I am
never drinking alcohol again after this
because before I was like I don't really
drink I'll have something sometimes nah
nah I had a beer woke up and the whoop
was like you're dying and it was like
recovery was like 100 and I was like
what I have like one beer and then I was
like maybe it's anomalous so the next
weekend I was like oh yeah I had a
Yingling at the casino next day three
percent apocalyptically bad and then I'm
like okay I'm gonna try not drinking a
beer and Recovery was stable so I'm like
alcohol really does screw up yourself
absolutely it's so horrible for you and
especially your sleep but if you're
doing it at night it's it's like the
worst thing for your liver your brain it
shrinks your brain people don't
understand this after my brain injury
one of the things that my neurosurgeon
told me was like it doesn't matter
because he's a Canadian like from
Saskatchewan so deep Canadian accent you
know and he's like I don't care if the
boys win or lose you can't have a beer
it's like the one thing you can't do it
damages your brain people don't
understand this fairly I've been off a
booze except for that one time on the
show and we celebrated the purchase of
Twitter remember that yeah that was the
only time and then other than that I
don't remember I don't remember any
other time drinking and I feel amazing a
teeny little bit I took a little bit
yeah yeah all right let's see we got
here speechless by Michael Knowles what
a great name yeah are they still doing
that in the chat oh yeah yeah repeal the
National Firearms Act of 1934. it is and
always was a gross infringement on the
only right that explicitly says it
should not be curtailed under any
circumstances funny how that works isn't
it was that response to machine guns
being invented
it was because of the gangs but you know
the the pistol brace band is total BS
the ATF is not Congress they can't just
decide you have an illegal thing yeah oh
we've decided your brace is illegal now
you can't do that it's up to Congress to
decide that yeah
we'll see what happens man well they're
just trying to register you know people
right now and I think it's going to be
ruled unconstitutional just like the
bump stock was recently as well so but
are they are they appealing that the
bomb stock ban um I don't know what's
what's going to happen but I just know
it was repealed once they're probably
going to challenge it again and it might
go to the Supreme Court
I think the bump stock ban was also
unconstitutional the government can't
just decree things are illegal Congress
has to make a law
all right Stephen says Hunter paid for
everything with money his daddy made for
him
that's right and he paid for them
one pissed off if he says fifty thousand
dollars on rent 4.99 and parmesan cheese
yikes
what a what a what a horrible life story
yeah he pulled parmesan on the carpet to
smoke so because he was desperate for
crack
damn dude nowhere to go but up
kalishnikov says Tim I know it's causing
all the sudden heart related deaths
someone has procured a Death Note and is
writing down all the names that's the
only explanation yeah someone got like a
male chimp email hold on this is funny
actually hacked thing for those that
aren't familiar
death MailChimp uh database in Death
Note for those not familiar with the
with the manga or the show
a high school kid gets a notebook called
the death note if you write someone's
name in it and a cause of death within
physical possibility it will happen if
you write their name with no cause of
death they'll have a heart attack and
what is it 27 days or something like
that yeah there's I don't know if the
time is is defined but they will die if
you write it more times they'll die
sooner left like once I think it's 27
days or something like that yeah the
time is defined so uh the main character
starts killing criminals he sees on TV
and in the news without a cause of death
so they all just randomly have heart
attacks yeah because he wants people to
see a pattern there's a funny thing
in the show eventually the the the the
cops find a pattern they're like all
these criminals are having heart attacks
there must be something happening
and these days in this day and age right
now with all people having heart attacks
they're like climate change right it
makes sense it makes sense it's normal
yeah
what were people saying 27 was it 27
days you have six minutes oh six minutes
40 seconds not 27 days is that what it
was
uh uh I remember it was like it was
pretty rapid like if we'd write
someone's name in the book and it
happened pretty quickly if you read it
more times oh all right that's what it
was
it was that you could write up to 27
days I think maybe not 27 but it was
like you could write the cause of death
and extend the time frame out 27 days
something like that right yeah
people are saying 60 Seconds
six minutes
yeah but wasn't it there like he timed
things out to where
people for people who are who know the
show where he'd be like this guy will
die on this date at this time and he
would like write it out weeks in advance
or something like that
what did someone say six minutes 40
seconds
6 minutes 40. well there you go six
minutes 40 seconds we get it that's a
Death Note someone's got it yeah
all right let's grab some more
Mike says Tim the Dems are going after
Biden so they can justify barring Trump
from running in 2024. good point it's
possible they go for the documents they
say you gotta forfeit oh but that means
Trump too
see we're being fair
yeah it's possible
1 and 20 million says I like this guy
he's based Ian keep rolling 20s by
Bitcoin
yeah what's Bitcoin up to now
uh I just jumped is it popping up yeah
it's jumping over 21k it is
21.05 wow yeah from being down to like
16.
Bitcoin
yeah I believe in BTC yeah
this person's name is Clint Orris he
says I tried
what do you guys like what are you guys
laughing about uh what are you guys like
we'll tell you after the show oh okay Mr
Orris is probably a mistake says
I tried searching Joe Biden Hunter Biden
on Google News Tab and I got a single
page of results and did it say the
results are changing rapidly check back
later is the source reputable
that's how they censor News man they
will not need to rewrite history they're
rewriting it as we go yeah
all right
agamemnon's gym bag says this is a
motion to have Luke cast during Davos
hmm
I am reporting on the whole Davos thing
and having a team of people look at
everything that they're doing and uh
covering in on my YouTube channel we are
changed how's it been
um they just started today was the
opening ceremony and they were just
saying climate emergency climate
emergency climate emergency give us all
your power and money now and uh that's a
short just uh summary of everything yeah
too much carbon dioxide I was like well
we can pull it out and turn into
graphing I mean too much methane I was
like okay we can turn the methane into
carbon dioxide and then here's celebrity
with endorsed uh you know saying and
they're vegans
all right
where were you uh Cain Abel says it
won't be a pill it will be a robot the
person in charge will say you can live
forever but you won't your soul will not
be there you will be a slave like the
necron oh my gosh
oh my gosh you know you'll uh they've
already they've already recreated you on
Facebook AI
you hear the story about how they can
take all your posts and messages and
everything about you and then create an
AI chat bot based on you yeah all they
need is they do that when you're alive
yeah don't be surprised if one day a
robot knocks on your door you open the
door it's you and you're like what it's
like I'm you and then it stabs you and
you're like it replaces you they I think
all of the networks are combining data
all our phones are recording all our
words and so they'll they'll what'll
happen is either
a new corporate governance will will
come in with the world record with a new
world order and we'll be like oh no and
then they will mandate all the tech
companies to compile the data for them
to create the Uber Consciousness
otherwise we can make uh you know
decentralized Authority that would not
enforce those kind of things on people
that's that's my job and real quick the
CCP has more data on us than we have on
them yeah so that's a scary thing it's a
big problem Airbnb things like that they
turn over people's data to the CCP to
operate in China but whereas Tick Tock
like that's that's something severely
lacking we need to take control of tick
tock yeah well I think all of them
though sees tick tock
all right Randy f says 11 years ago I
got diagnosed with autoimmune disease
Wegener's GPA lost my kidneys last month
I learned there is now a pill to treat
and reverse
wow wow
we got to get Boca some stem cells
what's going on with it so we're just
talking about it and so I have a uh
we're taking him to New York and we're
gonna do stem cell therapy yeah 25th
he's a candidate so he's gonna have
blood drawn on the 25th then he's gonna
have stem cells put back in him on the
27th and then we'll keep you guys up to
keep you informed on this but I have to
imagine he needs more than one drink
yeah I think there's three over the
course of six months I don't know we'll
find out it's a multi-treatment though
man I know I'm worried waiting that long
yeah I'm thinner and thinner you know
it's the other the other the other route
is just wait until he dies so I'm into
it yeah you know it's better than
nothing
he's uh he's getting hormones that
stimulate uh red blood cells and he's
getting uh IV electrolyte therapy but
it's it's been brutal because he he's
like sometimes he won't eat
and like we came back and he like he
didn't eat all day and we have to like
try and make it so I'm putting catnip in
his food and then he'll eat it which is
good and then he just drinks water
non-stop do you notice with cats we're
like they won't eat won't eat and then
you like Crouch down next to him and pet
them and then they just start eating
like if it's a mood thing like if they
get into a mood they'll just start
eating I don't know about all that all I
know is you put some cat drugs in his
food and he eats it yeah like humans are
the same way you know cancer patients
and smoke them smoke some pot and they
start eating you know that's why we need
medical uh medical advancements medical
marijuana I don't know if that's what
you're gonna say that's what I'm saying
well yeah I should be like General
advancements it's like not just
marijuana there's a bunch of stuff like
the guy's kidney pills yeah true stem
cells man people were saying that stem
cells was like taken from babies and
it's like turns out they can get it from
you yes they're gonna get bucko's own
stem cells oh that's coming from his own
fat from his own body and then they
replicate it and then put it right back
in
and then what yeah it's crazy it goes to
where the damage is and starts repairing
it that's crazy man but I'm concerned
that if his kidneys are totally shut
down and dead he won't do anything yeah
the kidneys have to be like still but
they are they they let me know due to
his test results that he's a viable
candidate because his kidneys are still
at like stage three renal failure it
hasn't quite entered stage four real and
failure and we got him on the kidney
food and the medicine so hopefully it's
like stabilizing
yeah low phosphorus or something
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
all right
Josh V says saw an article or something
a couple weeks back that said to the
effect we are a few years away from all
encryption being obsolete with Quantum
Computing advancements at current Pace
yep I've been talking about that yeah a
few years now but then we'll have
Quantum encryption
hopefully hopefully it's it's well the
people who develop it might keep it uh
for themselves right
they might not really sit to the public
or they might just uh privatize could
you imagine Quantum encryption that the
keys are changing in real time in
superposition yeah they have things
called time crystals where it's the
crystals in motion and it's the actual
motion of the crystal itself that's uh
that's the shape of it is the motion of
it so they're using that for encryption
tactics wow
C2 gaming says Media Matters are the
perfect example of professional
bigotering look at the definition it
needs to be used more frequently okay
yeah we want to look up bigger tiering
bigotering that's a good word yeah all
right
sa federally says 2024 hear me out both
go to prison bump stock Donnie gets I'm
not reading that trial by combat winner
gets to run loser stays in the yard
forever also if you thought Enigma
encryption was good wait until you hear
about WEP
Danny
yeah
yeah
Wes Eisman says Tim did you do a dark
slide this weekend while skateboarding
you know why I would never do a dark
side it ruins your grip what's that it's
when you flip the board over you like
kickflip or heel flip and then slide
upside down on the board and it just
mutilates the top of your board so like
it's a cool trick
for like the end of your board's life to
get on film and then not do again yeah I
don't know no dark slides for me no I
did a gnarly gazelle second try
real smooth too sounds like we need to
develop a material that'll allow it to
slide but also maintain grip
yeah what there's also they have this
like foam rubber grip which like doesn't
destroy your shoes and it works I'm not
a big fan of them I like my sandpaper
yeah I think it works
pinochet's helicopter tour says World
War II German concentration camps used
IBM Punch Cards yep that's true yeah
now imagine if everyone had cell phones
back then yeah true or in China
or in Russia
just Jimmy says shout out to Raymond the
chat isn't the same without you Tim load
up some local honey D3 and I shot at the
good stuff great guest heart the rip
reverse rip reverse shirt oh priest yeah
yeah I'm a big when I got uh red pilled
right when the pandemic started the
summer of love I started finding comic
Dave Smith Eric July shout out to them
and the libertarian party is for Real on
Tim Caster is a great article on renal
reset the best article that was written
um I forget who did was Chris wrote the
article I believe and um the libertarian
party is for real shout out to the mises
caucus I'm a fan yeah the music guys are
great we gotta have uh Dave on soon he's
doing a show out in Maryland I think on
what the 27th oh man Dave come through
uh I think we're gonna go there awesome
but we're trying to figure out we're
trying to figure out a date Dave can
come back so we try to figure it out
because we're booked up solid so we're
like let's see what we can do but uh I
think we'll be at Dave's show that's
Dave's greatest Dave can be funny but he
can also like give you the most base red
pilling of information about the Saudis
it's just so great you know so much
stuff yeah it'll be cool though so uh
you wanna you wanna look up actually
when it shows it oh yeah what is this
Dave Smith Dave Smith show
this website because it because I think
we'll all be there that'll be really
cool everyone should show up we'll sell
out the place everyone will laugh and uh
you know we'll get hot dogs or something
I love it yeah you did the it would be a
live show right with people there well
Dave's doing stand-up okay when is it
yeah I don't know do you see Maryland
did you find it
coming up well he's looking 27 I think
is it there no no what's going on
Perryville Perryville Maryland oh there
it is January 28th 28th I was out by day
cool 28 Saturday be there be square
we'll be there that sounds cool well the
plan is Saturday right yeah the plans to
be there I got nothing else going on
right
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats
all right Winston Alexander says chat
GPT is woke I asked where are the
consenting adult females
attracted to older balding overweight
matters answer it is not appropriate to
derogatory or objectifying statements
well no lips of tick tock uh tweeted
earlier today I don't know if you saw it
she asked she asked it something
positive about gender affirming care and
it answered then she wanted something
like a tweet like against it and it said
no I can't do it now that is scary
considering how powerful AI is going to
be
yeah and where it's getting its data
sets from yeah yeah that should need to
be okay
I don't know if you saw this um Sheila
Lee from Texas did a hate bill today
well it's not going to go anywhere
because nobody's going to sign it but
that mentality bind with AI was at the
bill about banning white supremacy yes
scary stuff even though it's not going
anywhere but people need to understand
white supremacy by them is not oh you
know white supremacy it's like anything
in support of America I'm a white
supremacist to them exactly so saying
stuff like you should work harder that's
hate speech and the Bill said that
if you say something on a platform that
another person can see and then they act
violently you conspired to commit hate
crime best stochastic terrorism right
that's I guess and you know what they're
going after I think the most powerful
thing like online you know other than
meeting people in person are the memes
they're going after the memes I think I
I had a I had a guy on my channel uh c3p
meme excellent he's the guy who did I
don't know if you saw the um Sanford and
Son memes where he put Trump's face on
red fox
and everybody it doesn't matter what
your politics are they all love it I bet
you they would go after like simple
memes like that
all right this is important when Clint
Torres says Tim which is healthier heavy
cream or sugar-free organic coconut milk
I know heavy cream is far more tasty
which screams less healthy I actually
think
um both are are very very good well like
no sugar added organic coconut milk is
like one of the healthiest things ever
it is fatty and coconut oil is really
really good for you heavy cream probably
is worse for you but I don't think it's
that much worse for you I don't know
what do you think Ian I would think that
the coconut milk would be the best but I
do think they're both there's a lot of
somatic cells in in Dairy which are like
I don't know are there cancer they're
not cancer cells are causing but on top
of that coconut oil will be MCT oil too
which is medium chain triglycerides yes
and your brain can work faster on them
basically and I think they used to use
coconut water as saline yeah that's true
like when people are bleeding out the
war they take a coconut and they plug it
in because yeah because it could be it
could it could keep your blood pressure
up correct so uh a somatic cell for the
record as any cell of the body except
for sperm and egg cells for some reason
they're allowed the dairy industry is
allowed to have a certain number of
somatic cells found in milk and stuff
all food have that then yeah it's kind
of vague but what I've heard is that
it's actually the uh the the pus is like
they'll be like oh somatic cells they're
talking about how much plus they have in
there come on come on get organic farm
fresh heavy cream yeah because a lot of
us see antibiotics yeah from the
non-organic stuff yeah we we go to Mom's
Organic and we get this glass bottle
organic cream
and The Taste is just incredible it's
like when you see those cows hooked up
to machines they get infections on their
Udders and then you're drinking the
infected like that's the stuff to stay
away from yeah but so just go for the
organic stuff but um when I was when I
was when I went to the dairy farms in
California the cows are free range they
choose to get milked the cows walk to
the machine the machine milks them and
then they're happy and they walk out
yeah because if the milk builds up and
they can't get it out it hurts them
right so they walk in the machine
they're like get it and then the machine
yeah 10 to 12 gallons of milk per day
that's what I'm told
that's crazy all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com
because we do rely on your memberships
to keep the ship a sailing especially in
January because January is like
adpocalypse month there's no budgets in
you know contracts paid out last month
so like very little Revenue comes in
through ads but uh because of all of you
who are members we don't got much to
worry about so that really does mean a
lot to us so serious thank you all to
the members we're gonna have that
members only show coming up for you in
about an hour so don't miss it you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast Osiris you want to
shout anything out oh yes well thanks a
lot for having me first of all you guys
are class acts shout out to Cassandra
McDonald
um great time follow me anywhere Twitter
uh YouTube the website is middlemaga and
I want to put a human face humanize the
mega movement I really think it's the
most beautiful movement of my political
Lifetime and then the mises caucus and
the libertarian party is second so if
you agree if you're interested we got
people of all different perspectives I
have people on the populist left come on
so
um holler at me what was the website
again middlemaga.com all right thank you
so much for coming on that was great uh
really appreciate your voice on here uh
my website is Luke uncensored.com it is
my members area I did a video today on
all the things that I can't say here
specifically about Pfizer and the four
Pfizer celebrities one of which blocked
me you want to know which one blocked me
check out the video that I did today on
Lucan sensor.com also a lot of people
are asking when I'm going to be leaving
I'm going to be leaving this week so
I'll miss you guys
no that's fine we got a way better
replacement
I'm going up from here it's the cat you
guys can find me anywhere on the
internet at Ian Crossland happy to be
here and also Cyrus I wanted to shout
out your Twitter page stuck in the mid
it's stuck and the letter n d a m i d if
anyone wants to follow you on Twitter
good to see you man yeah thank you nice
meeting you hell yeah
and uh I am at sir dupriya or surge.com
my name is I'm serve.com everywhere on
the internet uh it's been a really good
show pleasure meeting you and uh yeah I
am really gonna be sad to see Luke go
damn right thank you at least someone
here is we will see you all over at
timcast.com for the members only show in
about one hour thanks for hanging out
cheers